I'm going to do this.
So today is...
Oh, sorry.
Today, we're going to have a nice...
Sean, no, sorry.
It's just the last time you started the last one.
I was going to start this one.
Okay.
我要这么做了。所以今天是……哦，抱歉。今天，我们要进行一次美好的……肖恩，不，抱歉。只是上次是你开始的。本来我想开始这个的。好吧。
We're just doing an intro.
So we'll do it.
So I'll just go.
So today...
Oh, I thought...
Let me just do it.
Listener, here is smart.
我们只是在做开场白。所以我们会做的。所以我就直接开始了。所以今天……哦，我以为……让我来吧。让我来吧。听众朋友们，这个很聪明。
By the...
Okay.
Smart.
Listen, I think it's been three weeks
since we've done this.
since I've seen you, since I've talked to you.
And I have to say, I've had some long drives in the last three weeks,
so I've gone ahead and done some quality control, listening to our podcast.
顺便说一句……好吧。聪明。听着，我想我们已经有三周没做这个了。自我见到你、自我和你交谈以来。我必须说，在过去的三个星期里，我有过几次长途驾驶，所以我提前做了一些质量控制，听了我们的播客。
I'm not great at it because I'm listening to them after they've already reached the public.
Are you picking up some long hauler miles, some deliveries?
What's going on?
I am.
I've got some five-hour energy cases I'm trying to get through.
Okay, sure.
So it's really been nice listening to you, fellas.
You're both very talented and very funny on the podcast.
我在这方面不太在行，因为我听的时候它们已经公开发布了。你这是在跑长途、送快递吗？怎么回事？是的。我有几箱“5小时能量”饮料想喝完。好吧，当然。所以听你们几个聊天真的很开心。你们俩在播客里都非常有才华，非常搞笑。
I'd really like to be more of a part of it.
So I was very excited to...
A part of it.
I was very excited to see you guys today.
But then this morning...
This morning, a real dark cloud floated over our family here at SmartLus.
Jason, can I just...
Is it possible to say,
我真的很想更多地参与其中。所以我非常兴奋能……参与其中。今天能见到你们，我非常兴奋。但今天早上……今天早上，一片真正的乌云笼罩了我们SmartLess的大家庭。杰森，我能……有没有可能说，
is it possible for a dark cloud to then give you a gut punch?
Is that possible?
Sure.
What happened?
Yeah.
Well, why don't you take it from here?
Well, Jason read something that I read.
We all read it.
一片乌云有没有可能给你当胸一拳？这可能吗？当然。怎么了？是啊。好吧，你从这儿接着说吧？好吧，杰森读了我也读过的一篇文章。我们都读了。
Well, I read it after you sent it to me.
Here we go.
Actually, you know what, Sean sent it.
Sean sent it before I read it.
Uh-huh, I don't think so.
Sean sent an article to Jason and me in the thread that we're in.
With some feigned exclamation points.
Like, hey, y-h-ha.
好吧，我是你发给我之后才读的。我们开始吧。其实，你知道吗，是肖恩发出来的。在我读之前，肖恩就发了。呃，我不这么觉得。肖恩在一个我们都在的聊天群里发了一篇文章。带着一些假惺惺的感叹号。就像，嘿，呀哈。
This is great for us.
And by the way, I'm going to put it out there.
If anybody thinks they're worthy of being in the text thread, let us know.
We'll add you.
We'll add you to the thread.
And Sean says, congrats for us.
Yay, for us.
And it's a click to Hollywood Reporter, SmartList nominated.
这对我们太棒了。顺便说一句，我要在这里说明一下。如果有人觉得自己配得上加入这个聊天群，告诉我们。我们会加你的。我们会把你加到群里。肖恩说，恭喜我们。耶，为了我们。点击进去是好莱坞报道，SmartLess入围了。
Great.
Nominated for a bunch of podcast awards or whatever.
Which is kind of neat because this is, you know, this is an embarrassment.
It's a mom and pop operation, yeah.
We apologize.
Yeah.
The fact that we're getting any traction whatsoever, let alone nominations.
Just thank you to all the folks out there.
太棒了。入围了一堆播客奖项什么的。这挺酷的，因为你知道的，这是一个让人尴尬的小作坊，是的。我们道歉。是的。我们能得到任何关注，更不用说入围了。感谢所有的听众朋友们。
It's pretty great.
Thank you.
And also it's embarrassing.
Jason's right.
It is kind of embarrassing.
So then if you read further down on the story,
they're nominated Best Podcast, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And Sean Hayes nominated for Best.
这真的很棒。谢谢。而且这也挺尴尬的。杰森是对的。这确实有点尴尬。接着如果你往下读报道，他们入围了最佳播客，巴拉巴拉巴拉，然后肖恩·海斯入围了最佳。
best host.
Which is the kiss of death, because now everybody's like, well, he's not really that great.
Well, you're...
I don't think they're saying it out of the side of their mouth either.
I think it comes straight out the center.
Straight out.
And here's my thing.
Today, I can't wait to see you host.
最佳主持人。这就是死亡之吻，因为现在每个人都在想，好吧，他其实也没那么优秀。好吧，你……我觉得他们也不是言不由衷。我觉得这是发自内心的。发自内心。我的想法是这样的。今天，我迫不及待地想看你主持了。
Yeah.
Let's see what you got.
This is going to be the worst experience for me.
Well, the voters are now listening, right?
Because the nominations are out.
Now they really have to decide.
Pay attention to his hosting.
My questions are still going to be like, hey, where are you from?
是啊。让我们看看你有什么本事。这对我来说将是最糟糕的体验。好吧，评委们现在都在听，对吧？因为提名已经出来了。现在他们真的得做决定了。注意他的主持。我的问题依然会是，嘿，你是哪里人？
Yeah, no, don't worry.
We know that.
That obviously resonates with the jury over there.
The I heart media people have made a bunch of mistakes here.
When Sean said, what's your favorite color?
I mean, how do you talk about these?
Let's nominate that, jackass.
Yeah, here we go.
对，不，别担心。我们知道这一点。这显然能引起那边评审团的共鸣。IHeartMedia的人在这里犯了一堆错误。当肖恩说，你最喜欢什么颜色？我的意思是，你怎么会问这些？提名那个混蛋吧。对，我们开始吧。
Jesus, I'm not going to be able to come up for air for a while.
We're thrilled for you, Sean.
Yeah, we really are.
I'm thrilled for everybody.
I said to Sean, by the way, I did say, congrats, man.
And he was like, oh, thank you.
And I responded, I didn't mean it.
What do you?
天哪，我有一会儿喘不过气来了。我们为你感到高兴，肖恩。是的，我们真的很开心。我为所有人感到高兴。顺便说一句，我对肖恩说过，恭喜你，老兄。他的反应是，哦，谢谢。我的回答是，我不是认真的。你这是在……
What are you doing?
How dare you say, thank you.
I responded with, I didn't, I didn't read the, I truly didn't know, I didn't read the article.
I just read the headline, like most people.
Sure.
It is true.
I think Sean might be the kindest man I've ever met.
Not possible.
你在干什么？你怎么敢说谢谢。我的回答是，我没有，我没有读，我真的不知道，我没有读那篇文章。我只是像大多数人一样看了标题。确实如此。这倒真的。我觉得肖恩可能是我见过最善良的人了。不可能。
No one deserves it more.
Not around you too.
All right, zip it up.
We've got, we've got an interesting guest today.
He's known primarily in New Zealand and South Africa due to his success in rugby.
Okay.
Florida then came to love him when he pivoted his talents towards Highline and dog racing.
And then when he was in California, it was attempting to be the first to successfully mend the San Andreas fault.
没有人比他更配得上了。别在你们两个周围。好了，闭嘴。我们今天有一位有趣的嘉宾。他主要因橄榄球的成功而在新西兰和南非闻名。好吧。后来当他把才能转向高空走钢丝和赛狗时，佛罗里达开始爱上了他。然后当他在加利福尼亚时，他试图成为第一个成功修复圣安德烈亚斯断层的人。
He tried his hand at acting.
And while fame and fortune there has been scarce at best, some call it a wipe out.
Sure.
The critics have given him a few hugs.
So he has received a couple of Academy Awards and seven Emmy Awards.
What?
He's gotten himself a Tony.
nomination.
他尝试过演戏。虽然那里的名利可以说是寥寥无几，有人称之为彻底失败。当然。评论家们给了他几个拥抱。所以他获得过几次奥斯卡奖和七次艾美奖。什么？他还获得了托尼奖提名。
What's an AFI player who has a
Academy Award? He turned it around. He got a
Lifetime Achievement Award from AFI.
B. FTA gave him something.
The Golden Globes gave him the
Cecil B. DeMille Award.
The Kennedy Center honored
this High Life Player.
哪个获得过奥斯卡奖的AFI演员？他扭转了局面。他获得了AFI的终身成就奖。BAFTA给了他一些东西。金球奖授予了他塞西尔·B·德米尔奖。肯尼迪中心向这位高空走钢丝演员致敬。
And Barack Obama gave him
the Presidential Medal of Freedom.
So I say chin up.
I say chin up to this fella.
I have no idea. This is the most
highly decorated guest we've ever had.
I would say so, yet he's famous and fortunate in our book, okay?
Please welcome the forever struggling, but always diligent.
巴拉克·奥巴马授予了他总统自由勋章。所以我说振作起来。我对这家伙说振作起来。我毫无头绪。这是我们邀请过的获得荣誉最多的嘉宾。我这么认为，但在我们看来，他名利双收，对吧？请欢迎永远在挣扎但始终勤奋的、
America's own in Hollywood's best, Mr. Tom Lamar Hanks.
No.
Had I known that Sean was the host of this podcast?
I would have bailed.
I said, guys, I'd like to, but, you know, I don't like to work from home.
Apparently, you're working with one of the brightest hosts in the business.
Is there a name for this award?
Is it, does it named after somebody?
美国本土及好莱坞最优秀的汤姆·拉马尔·汉克斯先生。不。如果我知道肖恩是这个播客的主持人？我就会退出了。我说，伙计们，我很想去，但是，你知道的，我不喜欢在家办公。显然，你正在和业内最聪明的主持人之一合作。这个奖有什么名字吗？它是用某人的名字命名的吗？
It's called the aorta, because it's from IHeartMedia.
Oh, okay.
That's not true, but that's my pitch.
One of my heart-hitting nominee questions is, where are you right now?
I don't recognize that room.
I'm in a tiny little cubby hole that is here in my vast compound.
Somewhere in the tri-state area.
I'm telling you, dog racing really pays guys.
它叫主动脉奖，因为它是IHeartMedia颁发的。哦，好吧。这不是真的，但这是我的推销。我那些尖锐的提名问题之一是，你现在在哪？我不认识那个房间。我在我庞大宅邸里的一个小隔间里。在三州地区的某个地方。我告诉你们，赛狗真的很赚钱，伙计们。
You've got to look into it.
It's within a single day's drive from Lakewood, Ohio.
Home of the Great Lake Shakespeare Festival.
Wait, you didn't.
Is it true?
No.
Are we already plugging a festival?
你们得了解一下。从俄亥俄州莱克伍德开车一天就能到。伟大的湖畔莎士比亚节的故乡。等等，你没有。真的吗？没有。我们已经在宣传一个音乐节了吗？
I mean, this is quick.
Well, it was a long time to go.
A long time ago.
Wait, did you really do dog racing?
No, you dumb ass.
This is why you're not going to win.
You're the worst host.
Jason was demonstrating his, quote, comedy chops.
我的意思是，这太快了。好吧，那是很久以前的事了。很久以前的事了。等等，你真的去赛狗了吗？没有，你这个笨蛋。这就是为什么你赢不了。你是最糟糕的主持人。杰森刚才在展现他的，引号里的，喜剧才华。
Yeah, boy, guys, can I write or what?
Huh?
Well, hang on.
I think Tom's on to something.
Let's get into Jason's comedy chops.
Real quick.
You know, I told some friends last night that I was doing this podcast,
and first of all, I had to re-explain your names.
是啊，天哪，伙计们，我会不会写作？啊？等等。我觉得汤姆说得对。我们来聊聊杰森的喜剧才华吧。快说。你知道，我昨晚告诉一些朋友我要做这个播客，首先，我不得不重新解释你们的名字。
Who we were, yeah, sure.
They said, Sean, who, Jason, what?
Will, huh?
What is the name of it?
Yeah.
I kept calling it helpless based on the Neil Young song.
So, but now I realize, no, no, no, it's smartless.
We really are helpless.
我是谁，对吧，当然。他们说，肖恩是谁，杰森是什么？威尔，哈？这名字叫什么？对。我一直根据尼尔·杨的歌叫它“无助”（helpless）。所以，但现在我意识到，不，不，不，是“聪明少根筋”（smartless）。我们确实挺无助的。
And the question came up about you, Will.
Uh-oh.
which was this question.
Has he started using a different voice professionally?
That in your early days, you were kind of like squeaky,
you sort of sounded like Jay North in those old Dennis the Menaceary runs,
and you were hilarious.
But then you went off and voiced Batman,
然后有人问到了关于你的问题，威尔。噢哦。问题是这样的。他开始在专业上使用不同的声音了吗？你在早期的时候，声音有点尖细，听起来有点像老版《丹尼斯威胁》里的杰·诺斯，你当时太搞笑了。但后来你去给蝙蝠侠配音了，
and it's as though you're walking around with their own self-imposed EQ
on your voice now all the time.
True or false, Will.
Listen, like any good politician, I can't just give you a straight true or false.
I will say that I constantly have a monitor in my ear
and I'm adjusting my levels, my input levels.
Right.
And so then I can monitor.
这就好像你现在走路时，随时都在给自己的声音加上一种自设的均衡器一样。真的还是假的，威尔。听着，就像任何优秀的政客一样，我不能直接给你一个非真即假的回答。我要说的是，我的耳朵里一直挂着一个监视器，我在调整我的电平，我的输入电平。没错。所以我可以监控。
No, you know what?
It's funny.
I recently, you know, I often watch a lot of my old stuff because I like to be entertained.
And he has trouble sleeping.
Yeah.
No, but my voice has gotten, it has.
But if you listen to Howard Stewart.
It's just because of abuse, I guess.
不，你知道吗？这很有趣。我最近，你知道的，我经常看我以前拍的东西，因为我喜欢自娱自乐。他睡眠有困难。是的。不，但是我的声音变了，确实变了。但如果你听霍华德·斯特恩的节目。这大概只是因为用嗓过度吧。
Do you still smoke?
Who's listening?
I'm just learning.
We had Sean Penn on the podcast.
He went through a,
full pack of darts, didn't he?
He did go through a pack of darts.
你还抽烟吗？谁在听？我只是在了解。我只是在了解。我们请过肖恩·潘上播客。他抽完了一整包香烟，对吧？他确实抽完了一整包烟。
That's colloquial for cigarette.
Yeah, it's Canadian.
As opposed to say, coffin nail or...
Yeah.
Or a nail.
A nail.
Or bullet.
Actually, Tom, this brings me to an actual question about the nail.
那是香烟的俗称。对，那是加拿大的说法。而不是像，棺材钉……对。或者一枚钉子。一枚钉子。或者子弹。其实，汤姆，这让我想到了关于香烟的一个真正的问题。
I noticed recently I was reading the 10th book in the Gunter...
What's his name?
Series by Philip Kern.
I noticed your name on the back of it.
Oh, oh, the...
You gave a little blur for the back of...
For the jacket of Prussian Blue, which I'm almost finished.
with. Oh, that's a great one.
我最近注意到我在读菲利普·克尔写的冈瑟系列的第十本……他叫什么名字？系列。我注意到封底上有你的名字。哦，哦，那个……你为……《普鲁士蓝》的护封写了一小段推荐语，我快读完了。哦，那本太棒了。
It's a great one, right?
Gunther...
Bernard Gunther...
Bernard Gunther.
Bernard Bernie Gunther series.
He plays a non...
Okay.
You explain it.
那本真的很棒，对吧？冈瑟……伯纳德·冈瑟……伯纳德·冈瑟。伯纳德·伯尼·冈瑟系列。他扮演一个非……好吧。你来解释一下。
Be merciful on me on this, okay?
He plays a non-Nazi
private investigator
from 1928 Berlin
through well after the war.
It's a fabulous series
by Philip Kerr.
Philip Kerr. The late Philip Kerr, he passed away. Yeah, no, too early, yeah.
在这件事上对我手下留情，好吗？他扮演一个来自1928年柏林的非纳粹私人侦探，一直经历到战后很久。这是菲利普·克尔写的一部极好的系列小说。菲利普·克尔。已故的菲利普·克尔，他去世了。对，不，太早了，是的。
And I read them all and just, well, I'm not a big, I'm not a big, like, detective genre fiction writer.
Me neither.
But this had that added bonus of very accurate sort of historical detail to it that I really loved.
It's a tremendous historical fiction, and you're absolutely right, and I'm with you, Tom, and I read mostly nonfiction.
And somebody recommended, they said, you love all this European history, I think you'd like this.
I'm fully, like I said, I just started
at the beginning of the summer, and I'm on book 10,
Prussian Blue. But he
我都读过了，而且，嗯，我不是一个狂热的侦探类型小说迷。我也不是。但这有个额外的红利，就是有我非常喜欢的非常准确的历史细节。这是一部极好的历史小说，你完全说得对，我和你一样，汤姆，我主要读非小说类。有人推荐说，你这么喜欢欧洲历史，我想你会喜欢这个。正如我所说，我整个夏天刚开始读，现在已经读到第十本《普鲁士蓝》了。但他
always refers to cigarettes as nails.
And he gets beaten up by these Nazis,
and then they look down and he's spitting up blood and they say,
what do you want? He looks up and he says, can I get a nail?
Yeah. And you know what?
When he smokes one, he looks really cool.
He looks really, really cool.
What I like about those books is
总是把香烟称为“钉子”。他被这些纳粹殴打，然后他们低头看着他吐血，问他想要什么。他抬起头说，能给我来根钉子吗？是的。你知道吗？当他抽上一根时，他看起来真的很酷。他看起来真的很酷，真的很酷。我喜欢这些书的原因是
it fills in the blanks of his war years
because some of them take place well before World War II.
Some of them take place after World War II.
and in the course of it, you see what he went.
Thanks, guys, for firing us out of the gate here at the start of the interview.
We know our listeners love literature.
Go, Sean.
You're the host.
它填补了他战争岁月的空白，因为其中一些故事发生在第二次世界大战之前很久。有些发生在第二次世界大战之后。在整个过程中，你可以看到他经历了什么。谢谢你们，伙计们，在采访一开始就把我们当靶子打。我们知道我们的听众热爱文学。加油，肖恩。你是主持人。
Let's do it.
Yeah, host.
Come on.
By the way, Sean, I have my hand on my buzzer.
Hand is right on my buzzer.
I'm ready to buzzer with the correct answer.
Good.
I want to know what your fascination with war is.
开始吧。是的，主持人。来吧。顺便说一句，肖恩，我的手放在蜂鸣器上。手就放在蜂鸣器上。我已经准备好用正确答案按铃了。很好。我想知道你为什么对战争这么着迷。
Because your name is so synonymous.
I've never asked you this in my entire life.
Why are you so passionate about the war guy?
The history of war.
He loves a good fight.
It started the highlight, I think, right?
That dog racing.
You know, first of all, we do a lot of them because none of the projects have to have cell phones or laptops.
因为你的名字与战争紧密相连。我这辈子从来没问过你这个问题。为什么你对战争这么热衷？战争的历史。他喜欢打仗。这一切是从高空走钢丝开始的，我想，对吧？还有赛狗。你知道，首先，我们做了很多这类题材，因为这些项目都不需要手机或笔记本电脑。
So that alone makes the writing of them so much easier.
And there's much less special effects of having to put in those screens.
But I get this question asked to me quite often.
and the answer always comes down to when,
in those formative years of, say, seven through,
you know, when you're a little kid,
every single caregiver, every single adult in my life
would make references to the six, two words, three letters each,
仅此一点就让剧本创作变得容易多了。而且需要后期加入那些屏幕的特效也少得多。但我经常被问到这个问题。而答案总是归结为在那些形成性格的岁月里，比如说七岁到……当你还是个小孩子的时候，我生活中的每一个照顾者、每一个成年人都提到过那场“六”（两个字，每个字三个字母），
the war.
And they talked about it as this great dividing line in their lives.
There was before the war, there was during the war,
and there was just after the war.
And they talked about it as though it's almost like,
well, that was when the black plague was walking among us, you know.
For a big chunk of their lives,
they had no idea where they were going to be in another six months.
这场战争。他们把它称为他们生命中的一道巨大分水岭。有战前，有战中，还有战后不久。他们谈论它的语气，几乎就像是……那是黑死病在我们中间游荡的时代，你知道的。在他们生命的大部分时间里，他们根本不知道再过六个月自己会在哪里。
They had no idea how long the war was going to last.
That's one big aspect of it.
The other part of the two is that the bad guys lost.
At the end of the day, we were able to somehow,
unfortunately necessarily kick the stuffing out of them.
And when bad guys lose something,
it's that, what is that power of myth of,
is it Bill Moyers, you know,
他们不知道战争还要持续多久这是其中的一个大方面。另一个部分是，坏人输了。归根结底，我们不知怎么能够、而且不幸地必须把他们狠狠揍了一顿。当坏人输掉某些东西时，那是……比尔·莫耶斯谈到的那种神话的力量吗？
the world was on a quest to defeat people
that were undeniably evil,
the governments of those places,
and many of the populace.
So I keep getting drawn back to that.
And again, I will say that from a storytelling perspective,
our present day is just so,
there is no shame left anymore.
世界一直在寻求击败那些不可否认是邪恶的人，即那些地方的政府以及许多民众。所以我一直被吸引回那个主题。再次说明，从讲故事的角度来看，我们现在的时代实在是……已经没有任何羞耻心可言了。
Truth seems to be a malleable, viscous, kind of like...
It's a distant memory truth, it seems like.
And actually, you know what, Tom, Sean actually,
within the last six months, I don't know if you remember,
we were talking about all the movies you've done,
the war movies, and Tom said,
do you think he'll ever make a movie about TikTok?
And, you know,
真理似乎变成了一种可塑的、粘稠的东西……真理仿佛成了一个遥远的记忆。事实上，你知道吗，汤姆，肖恩在过去六个月里……我不知道你记不记得，我们谈到了你拍过的所有电影、战争电影，汤姆说，你觉得他会拍一部关于TikTok的电影吗？而且，你知道的，
because something that he thinks is important.
How about it to get right now?
For Sean and Scotty, there's before TikTok
and then after TikTok.
Well, you know, if I did, it would only be about 45 seconds long.
How long is your average TikTok?
And then I won't be able to wait for the sequel.
Tom, I know that you'd never compare your experience
因为这是他认为重要的事情。现在对肖恩和斯科蒂来说，有TikTok之前和TikTok之后。好吧，你知道的，如果我拍的话，它只会持续大约45秒。你平均的TikTok视频有多长？然后我就会迫不及待地等待续集了。汤姆，我知道你绝不会把自己拍摄
shooting, Save a Private Ryan,
to those who actually fought, you know, in all of that and during all that.
But was there ever a moment, I'm sure,
I bet there was a few moments while you were shooting that
where you got close to the feeling maybe of what it might have been
I mean, certainly the product, the result of that film took me there or as close as I think I could get.
But I would imagine there were a few moments there where it just, based on the quality of the production,
they managed to create some environments for you there and your own process of trying to get into the character and the realism of it,
《拯救大兵瑞恩》的经历，与那些在所有这一切中真正战斗过的人进行比较。但在拍摄过程中，我确信，我敢打赌，有那么几个时刻，你拍着拍着，可能有点接近那种感觉了？我的意思是，这部电影的产品、结果确实把我带到了那里，或者说尽可能地接近了我所能达到的极限。但我想象在拍摄过程中确实有几个时刻，仅仅基于制作的质量，他们设法为你和你的角色塑造过程、以及那种真实感创造了一些环境，
where you were kind of struck a bit by what these guys must have gone through?
Well, yeah, but at the same, it was all for.
fake, you know.
Sure, but I mean, you got to take that into account.
But when we were on the beach there in County Wexford in Ireland, which is where we shot
the Omaha Beach sequences.
Oh, so it wasn't right there?
Well, it was actually, it was one of the places where they rehearsed some of it.
让你对这些家伙当年的经历感到有些震撼？嗯，是的，但与此同时，这一切都是假的，你知道的。当然，但我的意思是，你得把这个因素考虑进去。但当我们身处爱尔兰韦克斯福郡的海滩时，也就是我们拍摄奥马哈海滩序列的地方。哦，所以不是在那个地方？嗯，实际上，那是他们排练部分场景的地方之一。
So that's one aspect.
How far was Bay's Camp from the beach?
Oh, it was way.
Well, I was going to incorporate that into the, into this anecdote.
Sorry, sorry.
So shut.
Just light up another nail, Will.
and take that pause.
所以这是一个方面。大本营离海滩有多远？哦，很远。嗯，我本来打算把这个融进这个轶事里的。抱歉，抱歉。所以，闭嘴。威尔，再点燃一根钉子吧。享受那个暂停。
We're there with 500 members of the Irish,
actual members of the Irish Army.
There is landing craft everywhere,
and we're all storming the beaches.
And the special effects crew
had laid out these tiny little flags
on the beach where they had set up
air mortars and squibs,
我们和500名爱尔兰军队的成员、爱尔兰军队的实际成员在一起。到处都是登陆艇，我们都在冲锋陷阵。特效团队在海滩上布下了这些小小的旗帜，他们在那里设置了空气迫击炮和炸药包，
little explosive devices.
Things to avoid.
Yeah, and they actually said,
you know, I be careful, eh?
right? Because, you know, this is going to become, this is like a projectile.
It'll come out of the ground very fast.
So if you can, try to avoid where the flags are.
You know, I think I got that.
小型爆炸装置。要避开的东西。是的，他们实际上说过，你知道的，小心点，嗯？因为，你知道的，这会变成，这就像一个抛射物。它会以极快的速度从地下钻出来。所以如果可以的话，尽量避开有旗帜的地方。你知道的，我想我明白了。
Then they removed all the flags, and we couldn't see anything.
Oh, my gosh.
So we were just stumbling all wandering blind.
So there's all of that, and it's dressed the way it is.
And when you, there were always four or five cameras going.
and once the shot began,
and you're wet and you're cold and you're coming up.
And at a corner of one eye, you see a guy catch on fire.
然后他们把所有的旗帜都撤了，我们就什么也看不见了。哦，天哪。所以我们只能跌跌撞撞地盲目摸索。所以这一切都有，而且场景布置就是那个样子。当你……总是有四五台摄像机在拍摄。一旦镜头开始，你浑身湿透，寒冷刺骨，往上冲。在眼角的余光里，你看到一个人着火了。
And at a corner of the other eye,
you see a guy blown 40 feet into the air,
and he loses a leg in the process.
Literally, we had, you know, amputee stunt people.
Oh, my God.
Then you'd continue to...
They were amputated before you shot.
They were amputated before.
在另一边眼角的余光里，你看到一个人被炸飞到40英尺的高空，并在过程中失去了一条腿。真的，我们有……截肢特技演员。哦，天哪。然后你继续……他们是在你拍摄之前就被截肢的。他们之前就被截肢了。
Thank God, just to clarify.
And even though there's harnesses and there's wires and whatnot,
machine guns are going off all around you
and explosions are happening like crazy.
And it goes on for the better part of, you know,
two or three or four minutes.
And there was a degree of sort of like odd, fake,
and yet at the same time, terror that was going on.
感谢上帝，特此澄清。尽管有安全带、威亚以及各种设备，机枪在你的四周疯狂扫射，爆炸声此起彼伏。这种情况持续了大半个，你知道的，两三分钟或四分钟。有一种奇怪的虚假感，但与此同时，那种恐怖感也是真实存在的。
Yeah.
So we were shooting then.
They're all morning along,
I'm going to say about on the,
maybe the second day of shooting,
because the first day of shooting was spent in the boats themselves.
And I climbed up the steps to the bluff.
They had put in these wooden steps so we could get up to the base camp, Will?
是的。所以我们当时在拍摄。他们一整个上午都在拍，我要说大约是在拍摄的第二天，因为第一天都花在船上了。我爬上通往绝壁的台阶。他们安装了这些木台阶，以便我们能爬到大本营，威尔？
Sure.
That's for catering and craft services.
Not far as the crow flies, but it was awfully high.
It was probably about six, seven hundred feet up the bluffs.
And I went back and I found the other guys in the unit who I would be meeting when we got up to the shale,
which was the defilade that was at the top of the beach.
That's where I would come across Barry Pepper.
and Eddie Burns and Vin Diesel and the other guys.
当然。那是为了餐饮和后勤服务。直线距离不远，但真的很高。悬崖大约有六七百英尺高。我回去找到了小队的其他人，我们在阶地会合，那是海滩顶上的隐蔽处。我在那里遇到了巴里·佩珀、
And they were still hanging around outside the trailers the way actors do.
Sure.
And I was wet and I was sandy and I was near death from the amount of noise that had gone on.
And I told the guys and said,
you guys better hold on to your hats because it's really wild down there.
You are not going to.
I mean, when you see a guy catch on fire out of the corner of your eyes,
and no one said, you know, talking.
埃迪·伯恩斯、范·迪塞尔和其他人。他们还在拖车外面闲逛，演员们通常都那样。当然。我浑身湿透，沾满沙子，由于巨大的噪音差点连命都没了。我对大家说，你们最好抓紧帽子，因为下面真的很疯狂。你们绝对不会……我的意思是，当你眼角余光看到一个人着火时，没有人事先说过。
No one's prepped you.
No one has said there's going to be a guy caught on fire on this side.
And it was an interesting kind of panic.
You know what's interesting?
And this is kind of folding back to what you were saying earlier.
One of the reasons that what I love about that movie, and I love that movie.
So much.
I'm not embarrassed to say.
没有人做过心理准备。没有人说过这边会有一个人着火。那是一种很有趣的恐慌。你知道有趣的是什么吗？这有点回到了你刚才说的话。我喜欢那部电影的原因之一，我太喜欢那部电影了。太喜欢了。我毫不掩饰地说。
I love it so much.
And I've seen it a lot of times.
And one of the things I really love about it, and you kind of touched on this whole idea of...
Can't wait for the musical version?
No.
97, by the way.
1997.
Which is insane.
我太喜欢了。我看了很多遍。我真正喜欢它的其中一点，你刚才也提到了这个概念……等不及要看音乐剧版了吗？不。顺便说一句，97年。1997年。这太疯狂了。
That's when it came out.
Wow, it seems like two years ago.
But you had that moment where your character is a school teacher, I think.
Is that right?
Yeah, yeah, we just...
Yeah, he's a school teacher.
But the idea that...
It doesn't matter what he is.
那是它上映的时候。哇，感觉像是两年前。但你有这样一个时刻，你的角色是一个学校老师，我想。是这样吗？对，对，我们刚……对，他是一个学校老师。但这个想法是……他是什么并不重要。
He's just a regular...
This is what the thing of this...
Particularly this war.
There was the Great War, which they referred to World War I as,
but then there was the war, this war, World War II.
And he was a guy who was called to do something extraordinary.
He wasn't a guy who was born to be of military.
officer. He wasn't a guy who was born to be a killer. He was a guy who had to go because that's
他只是一个普通人……这就是这部电影的特点……特别是这场战争。有一战，他们称之为第一次世界大战，但后来有了那场战争，这场战争，即第二次世界大战。他是一个被召唤去完成不平凡使命的人。他生来不是一个军官。他生来不是一个杀手。他是一个不得不去的人，因为那是
what he had to do. And people came in in this moment when the entire world was at war and did
extraordinary things. And I always loved that about it. And I think that for me, it really
captured what it is that sort of makes me have such, it's weird to have say have reverence for
the war, but you have reverence for the bravery and what people did that were extraordinary
things. You actually want to make an anti-war movie at the same time.
that you're making a war movie.
Let me tell you a story.
I was 18 years old, I think, and I was a bellman
他必须做的事。在全世界都陷入战争的这个时刻，人们挺身而出，做了不起的事情。我一直很喜欢这一点。我认为对我来说，它真正捕捉到了让我对战争产生这种……对战争产生敬意其实很奇怪，但你对人们所做的那些非凡事情的勇敢抱有敬意。你其实想在制作一部战争电影的同时，也制作一部反战电影。让我给你们讲个故事。我想我当时18岁，我是加利福尼亚州奥克兰皇家酒店的
at the Royal Hotel in Oakland, California.
And we had a guy who read his own dry cleaning service
would come and collect the clothes and take them away
and then deliver the clean clothes.
And he was always coming with dozens and dozens
of shirts and pants that had been dry cleaned.
And I was working there one summer
and he was gone for two weeks.
行李员。我们有个家伙负责招揽干洗业务，他会来收衣服，把它们带走，然后把洗好的衣服送回来。他总是带着几十件洗过干洗的衬衫和裤子来。那年夏天我在那儿工作，他离开两周。
I'm going to say his name was Mike.
I can't remember what his name was.
But Mike was gone for two weeks and somebody else came in every day.
And then after two weeks, it was in June.
After two weeks he came back from his vacation.
I said, oh, hey, Mike.
Where were these last two?
Oh, no, I take a vacation every June.
我姑且叫他迈克吧。我不记得他叫什么名字了。但迈克离开了两周，每天都有其他人来。然后两周后，那是六月。两周后他度假回来了。我说，哦，嘿，迈克。这两次你去哪了？哦，不，我每年六月都要度假。
I said, oh, oh, do you go camping?
No, no, no, I get together with some of my old buddies.
Oh, oh, where did you go?
Well, this year we went back to this place that we had visited back when we were kids.
I said, oh, where was that?
He said, it's in the north of France.
He was a paratrooper.
He was in the 82nd Airborne.
我说，哦，哦，你是去露营吗？不，不，不，我和一些老战友聚聚。哦，哦，你们去哪了？嗯，今年我们回到了小时候去过的一个地方。我说，哦，那是哪里？他说，在法国北部。他曾是一名伞兵。他在第82空降师。
Wow.
This guy is now, this 1974, so go back 40 years.
So he's in his 50s.
And what he's telling me is that when he was in his 20s, he jumped into Normandy on.
D-Day and he was a paratrooper.
And now he's a guy delivering his dry cleaning for the hotel.
I felt, I felt stupid and small.
But also, he was an example of that adult, that caregiver that was part of daily life.
哇。这家伙现在，那是1974年，倒回40年。所以他50多岁了。他告诉我的是，当他20岁时，他在D日跳伞降落在诺曼底，他是一名伞兵。而现在他只是个为酒店送干洗衣服的人。我觉得，我觉得自己既愚蠢又渺小。但同时，他也是那些融入日常生活中的成年人、那些照顾者的一个榜样。
That, you know, that, he didn't know if he was going to make it back.
And he went, oh, he said, and we go back, he said this.
He said, we go back to visit the buddies that didn't make it home.
So they're visiting the cemeteries that are in.
So look, that's a generation.
It was a time that was loaded with all sorts of problems
that, of course, we're still dealing with right now.
But you can't take away the fact that these were young guys
你知道的，他不知道自己是否能活着回来。他说，哦，他说，我们回去探望那些没能回家的战友。所以他们去参观墓地……所以看吧，那是整整一代人。那个时代充满了各种问题，当然，我们现在仍在处理这些问题。但你不能抹杀这样一个事实，那就是这些年轻人
who were asked to go off and liberate the world
from really, really bad people, and they did it.
Yeah.
My grandfather, I'll leave it at this.
My grandfather who passed almost 12 years ago,
who I was really close with and loved dearly.
I remember him telling me he worked with,
he was in the Canadian Army,
被要求去把世界从真正极度邪恶的人手中解放出来，而他们做到了。是的。我的祖父，我只想说这些。我的祖父在近12年前去世了，我和他非常亲近，深爱着他。我记得他告诉我他在……他是加拿大军队的，
but he was attached to the Royal Air Force,
and he planned bombing sorties.
And they were stationed at various airfields
as they would move across, as they, you know,
after June 44.
And he said, one morning we wake up
and there was constantly planes taking off and landing and stuff,
and they were right on.
但他隶属于皇家空军，他负责规划轰炸任务。随着战线的推进，他们在不同的机场驻扎，正如他们在……你知道的，1944年6月之后。他说，一天早晨我们醒来，不断有飞机起降之类的，他们就在附近。
And he said,
morning, the guy he shared a tent with, woke up, came out of the tent and walked into a
propeller of a plane in the dark.
And I said, and he told me, he didn't tell me this until I was about 18, of course.
And I said, well, what did you do?
And he said, and he wasn't joking.
He said, well, I got a new tent mate.
And I was like, wow.
他说，早晨，和他合住一个帐篷的家伙醒了，走出帐篷，在黑暗中直接撞上了一架飞机的螺旋桨。我说……他直到我大约18岁时才告诉我这些，当然。我说，那你做了什么？他说——他不是在开玩笑——他说，好吧，我换了个新帐篷舍友。当时我就想，哇。
And he was just like, that's the way it went.
We had to keep going.
What can you do?
I don't want to go into a place I was, that's too much of a bummer.
of his story, sad story, true story.
It's a very sad...
Anyway.
I think a perfect segue would be
他的态度就是，事情就是这样。我们必须继续前进。你能怎么办？我不想去一个……那太扫兴了。他的故事，悲伤的故事，真实的故事。这是一个非常悲伤的……不管怎样。我想一个完美的过渡应该是
happy days, right?
Sure, let's go.
Let's talk about...
Let's go to happy days.
In order to make saving private Ryan happen
or any of the other incredible movies that you have been in...
You IMDB reading Sons of B bitches.
How dare you?
《欢乐时光》，对吧？当然，我们走吧。我们来聊聊……我们去聊聊《欢乐时光》。为了让《拯救大兵瑞恩》得以实现，或者你拍过的其他任何不可思议的电影……你们这群看IMDB的混蛋。你们怎么敢？
This is pure Wikipedia.
How dare you come at me with this?
So had you not book that episode on Happy Days...
Hey.
Would you have not...
met Ron Howard and things we would not have been gifted the high-life player.
I did not meet Ron Howard on Happy Days. Ron had left the series by then. What I, the guys I met
were Lowell Gans and Babelou Mandel who were the staff writers on Happy Days who wrote the
这纯粹是维基百科。你们怎么敢用这个来质问我？所以，如果你没有接拍那集《欢乐时光》……嘿。你是不是就不会……遇到朗·霍华德，我们也就不会得到这位高空走钢丝演员了？我不是在《欢乐时光》上遇到朗·霍华德的。朗当时已经离开剧集了。我，我遇到的人是洛厄尔·甘斯和巴布鲁·曼德尔，他们是《欢乐时光》的编剧，写了
part, who wrote Splash, the screenplay of Splash. And Ron was directing and they said,
hey, you may want to, hey, take a look at that guy who got fired from bosom buddies, you know,
of Buzz and Buddies was canceled.
Something that Sean is going to experience one of these days.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
Sean's canceled two programs I've been on, so keep going.
And we will be right back.
那个角色，写了《现代美人鱼》的剧本。朗当时在导演，他们说，嘿，你可能想……嘿，看看那个从《亲密伙伴》里被开除的家伙，你知道的，《亲密伙伴》被砍了。肖恩总有一天也会经历这种事。是的。别担心。肖恩已经砍掉了我参与过的两个节目，所以继续吧。我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
Tom, would you agree that the routine of a sitcom actor
is the best job in show business?
Do you miss it still to this day?
Well, it is kind of a skate.
It's a great hang, I'll tell you that.
Because, look, if you either shoot,
You rehearse Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, camera block Thursday, shoot Friday.
现在，回到节目中。汤姆，你是否同意情景喜剧演员的日常是演艺界最好的工作？直到今天你依然怀念它吗？嗯，这确实挺轻松的。那是个很棒的去处，我得这么说。因为，你看，你要么拍摄……
Right.
Or you rehearse Thursday, Friday, Monday, camera block Tuesday, shoot Wednesday.
Isn't that kind of like the...
Yeah.
That second one shoots Tuesday, yes.
You start on Wednesday, yes.
What you're saying is five days of the week.
Yeah.
周一、周二、周三排练，周四机位排练，周五拍摄。没错。或者你周四、周五、周一排练，周二机位排练，周三拍摄。这不有点像……是的。第二个是周三拍摄，对。你的意思是每周五天。是的。
Unless you're working with Jimmy Burroughs, and then you can take the first day off of rehearsal
and really becomes a four-day work week, and it's only three weeks a month.
So it's 12 working days a month.
These are really top-secret things, man.
You should never let the civilians here.
What are you doing? Where are you blowing on?
And it's six hours a day.
是的。除非你跟吉米·伯罗斯合作，那样的话你可以把排练的第一天省下来，实际上这就变成了一个四周只有三周上班、每周工作四天的周。所以一个月只有12个工作日。这些真的是绝密的事情，伙计。你绝不能让平民听到。你在干什么？你在泄露什么？而且每天工作六个小时。
Now everybody's going to want to be in showbiz.
Oh, wait.
There's food. There's craft service.
Climate control.
You get a lot of breaks, you know.
It is an awfully fun day.
When we did bosom buddies, Peter Scaleri and I, my dear old pal.
One of the great shows.
现在每个人都想进演艺圈了。哦，等等。有吃的。有餐饮后勤。有空调。你有很多休息时间，你知道的。那是非常有趣的一天。当我们拍《亲密伙伴》时，彼得·斯卡利斯和我，我亲爱的老朋友。最棒的节目之一。
We actually shot that show on video, not on the film cameras.
Film cameras in those days, that was pretty much a bunt.
Camera blocking day was just kind of like your stand.
did it, but we had four video cameras, and we had to do the entire camera blocking day ourselves
on camera, because they did a line cut, you know, camera three, and tighten up on four, and four,
let's come back, let's coming back to two and two. You had to be there for that, so you did,
you worked a long day, and you did every line of the, that week script over and over again,
and he and I just started goofing around so much that that's, that's where we first got,
我们实际上是用录像带拍那个节目的，而不是电影胶片。那时的电影胶片，基本上就是个牺牲品。机位排练日基本上就是你的站位演练，但我们有四台摄像机，我们必须在摄像机前自己完成整个机位排练日，因为他们做现场切镜，你知道的，摄像机三号，四号拉近，四号，我们切回二号，切回二号。你必须到场配合，所以你工作时间很长，把那周剧本的每一句台词一遍又一遍地演，我和他开始疯狂地胡闹，那就是，那就是我们最初……
We got yelled at a couple of times.
You know, the director up in the booth, you know, he'd come in over that top.
The voice of God.
Hey, guys, listen, we're working really hard at here.
Can you guys just kind of skip to the lines?
Otherwise, we can't get the line cut in.
We're trying, check the tally lights on camera three, Tom.
When that comes on, you know, you speak.
我们被吼了好几次。你知道的，控制室里的导演，你知道的，他会通过那个对讲机传话。上帝之声。嘿，伙计们，听着，我们这里工作真的很努力。你们能直接念台词吗？否则我们没法做现场切镜了。我们在努力，汤姆，检查三号摄像机上的提示灯。那个亮了，你再说话。
And we didn't care.
We were just goofing around so much.
How excited were you when you got that show?
What was that moment?
So young Tom Hanks and you get bosom buddies,
booked it, it's your job, what was that?
Well, I couldn't believe it.
Yeah. I was going to be on TV, you know.
我们才不在乎呢。我们当时太爱胡闹了。当你接到那个节目时，你有多兴奋？那是怎样的一个时刻？年轻的汤姆·汉克斯接到了《亲密伙伴》，拿到了角色，这是你的工作，当时是什么感觉？嗯，我简直不敢相信。是的。我要上电视了，你知道的。
Right.
And I was going to be able, up to that point as a Shakespearean actor, I'd made, I made less than
$10,000 in a year for an entire year.
And I was married and I had a kid.
And, geez, I made almost, I made that in two weeks on, on bosom buddies.
So the financial reprieve was huge.
When was the last time you did Shakespeare?
I did Shakespeare two years ago here in Los Angeles
没错。而且我将能够……在此之前作为一名莎士比亚演员，我一年赚的钱不到1万美元。而我已经结婚了，还有一个孩子。天哪，我在《亲密伙伴》两周里赚的钱几乎……就达到了那个数。所以财务上的喘息空间是巨大的。你最后一次演莎士比亚是什么时候？两年前我在洛杉矶演过莎士比亚。
I played Falstaff
with the Shakespeare Center in Los Angeles
Tom tell that story
it was a video that I saw of you doing it
I can't remember it was so funny you pulled some guy out of the audience or something
what was no what happened was we had a medical emergency
a guy a gentleman had a heart thing
happened to him and all of a sudden the paramedics had to be called
我在洛杉矶莎士比亚中心扮演了福斯塔夫。汤姆，讲讲那个故事吧。我当时看了一个你演的视频，我不记得了，太搞笑了。你从观众席里拉了一个人还是怎么的，当时是……不，情况是这样的，我们遇到了医疗紧急情况，有一个绅士突发心脏病，突然不得不叫救护车。
we were doing it at the VA Center and the Japanese
garden amongst the eucalyptus trees here in west Los Angeles.
And, you know, a guy had some sort of seizure, and we had to call the EMTs.
And then we had to take a break in the house, not the house lights.
The lights all came up.
And it was going into, it ended up being about a 30-minute hold while they took care of
this general.
And we were all backstage saying, should we do something?
我们在退伍军人中心演，就在洛杉矶西区桉树林中的日本花园里。然后，你知道的，有个家伙突发某种癫痫，我们不得不叫急救人员。然后我们不得不暂停，不是观众席的灯。所有的灯都亮了。结果这成了大约30分钟的暂停，期间他们在照顾这位先生。我们在后台都在说，我们应该做点什么吗？
and then when I saw that people were leaving,
oh, no, no, no, no, no.
I mean, it was a long, it was about close to three-hour show anyway.
But when I saw people, I saw a lady pick up her purse
and move toward the exit.
And I came running out, trying to scream and get back here,
take thee, thy seat or something like that.
But what was amazing was you were improvising in Shakespearean talk.
然后当我看到人们开始离开时，哦，不，不，不，不。我的意思是，那本来就是一个将近三小时的演出。但当我看到人们，我看到一位女士拿起她的手提包朝出口走去。我冲了出去，大喊大叫着让他们回来，回到你的座位上或者类似的话。但神奇的是你在用莎士比亚的台词即兴发挥。
That's what blew my mind.
was super funny. God, it was so great.
It ended up being worthwhile and
it got enough people to stay.
And I think I ridiculed enough people
that made some lady cry, you know,
but out of laughter,
tears of joy.
这就是让我震惊的地方。超级搞笑。天哪，太棒了。结果证明这一切是值得的，而且留住了足够多的人。我想我还嘲讽了足够多的人，弄哭了一位女士，你知道的，但那是喜极而泣的眼泪。
What was the, you know, a splash?
By the way, for your birthday, years and years ago,
I sent you a poster and I superimposed my face
over Daryl Hannah's and I said,
the note said you and I would have made a bigger splash.
Tom doesn't remember that.
You had, we only been to Trailblazers.
But, but, you know, what was that, like, what was that feeling?
那个……你知道的，《现代美人鱼》？顺便说一句，很多很多年前，为了你的生日，我给你寄了一张海报，我把我的脸P到了达丽尔·汉娜的脸上，上面写着便条说，你和我本来可以掀起更大的波澜。汤姆不记得了。你只有过开拓者奖。但是，但是，你知道的，那种感觉是什么样的？
Because as a kid, I was like, oh, my God, every actor wanted to be Tom Hanks.
Everybody, every actor wanted to be you.
Yeah.
Still to this day.
You were in all of the string of these massive comedy hits, right?
And big and splash and just on what I was doing.
They asked me to be in a movie.
So I said, yeah.
因为作为一个孩子，我当时想，哦，天哪，每个演员都想成为汤姆·汉克斯。每个人，每个演员都想成为你。是的。直到今天依然如此。你参演了这一系列巨大的喜剧热门电影，对吧？比如《飞越未来》和《现代美人鱼》，就凭我当时在做的。他们邀请我拍电影。所以我说，好啊。
But did you know when you started doing all those other movies, you started, you did big and you did all these things.
and they were just getting, did you know where you were going or what?
No, no, you have no idea.
They just said.
You had no plan?
But you were playing the lead and you were incredibly charismatic and you were, you were compelling on screen.
Like you were carrying things right out of the gate.
Had you always had the confidence and the sort of the leadership qualities growing up?
但当你开始拍所有其他电影时，你拍了《飞越未来》和所有这些作品，它们越来越火，你知道你要去哪里吗？不，不，你根本不知道。他们只是说。你没有任何计划？但你扮演的是主角，你非常有魅力，你在银幕上极具吸引力。就像你一出道就能挑大梁。你从小到大一直都这么自信，并且自带领导气质吗？
No, no.
I was just trying to remember the words.
I was trying to speak loud enough to be heard.
But Tom, you are here.
you are such a relief listen i'll tell you i'll tell you the biggest the biggest lesson that i learned
this was when i was at the great lake shakespeare festival just a day's dry from where i am right now
in lakewood ohio um in which dan sullivan he's who directed the the uh the fall the
the fifth excuse me henry the fourth that i did his false staff he directed that in
不，不。我只是在努力回想台词。我试图大声点让别人听到。但是汤姆，你来了。有你真是太好了，听着，我跟你说，我跟你讲讲我学到的最大、最重要的一课，那是我在五大湖莎士比亚戏剧节的时候，离我现在所在的俄亥俄州莱克伍德只有一天的车程，当时丹·沙利文，他是导演，那个，第五幕，不好意思，我演的《亨利四世》里的福斯塔夫，他导演的那个
In 1977, we were in rotating rep, and I was carrying a spear,
and I was doing everything that I was told to do.
And we had just opened a production of Hamlet the night before.
It was in rotating rep, so you open the shows about every two weeks,
and then you ran a different show every night.
That's what repertory means.
And so we had opened up Hamlet,
and we all had a rehearsal the next day for,
在1977年，我们在轮演剧目，当时我只是个拿长矛的兵，导演叫我做什么我就做什么。就在前一天晚上，我们刚首演了《哈姆雷特》。因为是轮演剧目，所以基本上每两周就会首演一部戏，然后每天晚上演不同的剧目。这就是“轮演剧目”的意思。所以我们刚演完《哈姆雷特》，第二天大家又去排练，
Taming of the Shrew, which I played
Groomio in Taming of the Shrew.
And all of the equity company,
the professionals, were hungover, exhausted
because they had all been out partying the night before
because they had just opened Hamlet.
So everybody was like somnambulistic
and showing up at 10 o'clock.
《驯悍记》，我在《驯悍记》里饰演格鲁米奥。所有的联合剧团演员，那些专业人士，都带着宿醉和精疲力竭的状态来了，因为他们前一天晚上为了庆祝《哈姆雷特》首演成功，都在外面狂欢。所以大家看起来都像梦游一样，十点钟才晃晃悠悠地出现。
And no one really knew their lines yet,
and everybody was kind of like shuffling around.
And Dan Sullivan yelled at everybody.
He yelled at everybody.
He said,
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
We've got three weeks to get this show up on its feet.
而且根本没人背熟台词，大家都磨磨蹭蹭的。然后丹·沙利文冲所有人大吼。他冲每个人大吼。他冲所有人大吼。他说：“喂，喂，喂，喂，喂，喂！我们只有三个星期的时间把这出戏排练起来。”
And you people are not even trying for crying out loud.
I can't do my job if you guys don't do your jobs.
You guys have got to show up on time.
You've got to know your lines, and you've got to have an idea.
I can't provide everything here.
So let's take a break.
Mainline some coffee.
Chew it if you have to.
“而你们这群人甚至连试都不试，老天爷啊。如果你们不做好自己的工作，我也没法完成我的工作。你们必须准时到场。你们必须背熟台词，而且你们得有自己的想法。我可没法在这里提供一切。所以我们休息一下。去注射几针咖啡因。如果非得嚼的话，就嚼着吃。”
Right out of the jar.
But come back here.
with some friggin' energy.
Fuck, I would cast you in the Dan Sullivan movie right now, by the way.
Sorry, just for what it's worth.
That was incredible.
I remember, okay, so you look, we're all like 19, 18, 20.
I was 20 years old then, and that lesson really super stuck to me.
“直接从罐子里掏出来吃。但回来的时候，给我带上点该死的精力。操，顺便说一句，我现在就想把你选进丹·沙利文的电影里。抱歉，虽然这可能没啥用。刚才那段太精彩了。我记得，好吧，你看，我们当时都才19、18、20岁。我当时20岁，那一课真的深深地印在了我的脑海里。”
If professional actors who have 20 years in the biz, as they often said, 20 years in the biz,
I've never been yelled at like that.
That was an important list.
So all through all of these gigs that I had,
the hits thank you the misses let's forget those uh i always i that was always the thing that i thought
the most important thing to do was show up on time know your lines and have an idea in your
yes for sure for sure bring it that's that's all i did through all of those i didn't know anything so tom
when you went when you were doing all the strings the string of comedies uh back then and you
如果那些在行里摸爬滚打20年的专业演员——正如他们常说的“在行里混了20年”——说“我从来没被这样大吼过”。那是一次重要的教训。所以在我的所有这些工作里，无论是热门的——谢谢——还是冷门的（那些就忘了吧），呃，我总是……那一直是我认为最重要的事情：准时到场，背熟台词，并且在心里有个想法。对，没错，没错，拿出状态来。这就是我在所有那些工作中所做的一切。我什么都不懂。所以，汤姆，当你在当时接连拍了那一串喜剧的时候，你……
do you remember what it felt like or do you remember that pivot moment when all of a sudden maybe
you got offered a script or you had to you had to you had that you had to you
that kind of dialogue with your agent,
or what happened where you switched over to more,
let's say, important films or more dramatic films?
What a question.
It's so great.
Thank you.
你还记得那是什么感觉吗？或者你还记得那个转折点吗？就是突然间，可能有人找你拍剧本，或者你不得不……你不得不跟你的经纪人进行那种对话，或者发生了什么，让你转型去拍了更多，比方说，更有分量的电影或者更具戏剧性的电影？多么棒的问题。太棒了。谢谢你。
Oh, I can't.
That was the era of,
you could make a movie for about $15 million.
And if you just said it was a comedy,
it seemed to do some brand of business.
Whether it was actually funny or not,
it didn't matter.
Yeah, that was the time.
噢，我记不清了。那是这样一个时代：你只要花大约1500万美元就能拍一部电影。而且只要你宣称这是一部喜剧，它似乎就能卖出点票房。管它好不好笑，根本不重要。是的，那个时代就是这样。
You know, anybody who had said action
and cut was trusted to direct a comedy movie,
whether they were funny or not.
And I made a ton of those
in which everybody came back.
Oh, the Dailies were fantastic.
I think the audience is going to be standing on their feet
at the end of this.
你知道的，任何喊“开始”和“停”的人都被信任可以去导演一部喜剧电影，不管他们自己幽默不幽默。我拍了成吨这种电影，每个人回来都说：“噢，样片太棒了。我觉得观众看完这部电影肯定会起立鼓掌的。”
So, Tracy, Dailies are the thing you watch
as you're filming the movie.
They get little clips of the day before stuff.
And it doesn't matter if the movie was called
Monkeys Make the Sun Go Down.
Everybody would say, this is the,
funniest of all the movies.
The Cows of Tumble Town.
所以，翠西，样片就是你在拍电影时观看的东西。它们是前一天拍摄内容的片段剪辑。不管这部电影叫《猴子让太阳下山》还是别的什么，每个人都会说：“这是所有电影里最好笑的一部。”或者《笨蛋镇的奶牛》。
This is going to be a magnificent
comedy. Because
the good comedies that were made, you know,
at the time, they all had,
they were all with former Second City people,
you know, Saturday Night Live
people. But there was this,
you could take a setting.
“这将会是一部无与伦比的喜剧。”因为当时拍出的好喜剧，你知道的，都是由前“第二城”剧团的人，也就是“周六夜现场”的人演的。但当时有一种现象，你可以设定一个场景：
This movie takes place
on a ski slope.
This movie takes place on a school
bus. This movie takes place
at a bachelor party. And if,
It will be a comedy.
And I made a billion of those like that
because we're just kind of like doing imitations
“这部电影发生在滑雪场上。”“这部电影发生在校车上。”“这部电影发生在单身派对上。”然后，它就会成为一部喜剧。我拍了无数这样的电影，因为我们当时基本上就是在模仿
of other people's funny movies.
Yeah, but here's the thing, and I've said this about it,
there are a few people out there who have this,
and you are one of them, which is,
it doesn't matter what the movie was.
You are always good.
You're always, even doing, I joked about doing the Dan Sullivan.
No matter what it is, you're committed,
别人搞笑的电影。是的，但关键是——我曾经这样评价过——有那么少数人具备这种特质，而你就是其中之一，那就是：不管电影本身怎么样，你总是表现得很出色。你总是，甚至在演我刚才开玩笑说的丹·沙利文的那种戏时也一样。不管演什么，你都全情投入，
and that always kind of shines through.
So I know that you talk about those misses.
I mean, look, if it wasn't for bad movies,
I wouldn't make any at all myself.
You wouldn't be sitting in your dad's library.
Yeah, I wouldn't be my dad's living back at my folks house in Toronto.
But, you know, but it's true.
And you always deliver in that way because I always get the impression watching you
而这种特质总是能透过银幕闪耀出来。所以我知道你提到过那些失败之作。我是说，听着，要不是因为拍了烂片，我自己根本就不会接任何戏了。你也不会坐在你爸爸的书房里了。对，我也不会待在多伦多我父母家的客厅里了。但是，你知道的，事实确实如此。而且你总是能用那种方式交出完美的表现，因为我看着你的时候总有一种印象，
that like you don't care what the thing is.
You're just doing your, I mean, you're part of it and you're in the thing.
And who gives a shit?
You know, I don't want to discount some of the great stuff.
I met great people.
And we actually did some really funny stuff that really did work.
Yes.
It was always fun.
就像你根本不在乎拍的是什么烂片。你只是在做好你本分的事，我是说，你是其中的一部分，你融入到了那个东西里。谁他妈在乎呢？你知道的，我并不想贬低其中一些伟大的作品。我结识了很棒的人。而且我们确实拍了一些真正好笑且真正管用的东西。是的。过程总是很有趣的。
Also known as classics.
It was, well, you know, it's funny.
You know, I don't think we ever had a movie.
Splash was well reviewed.
And I don't think I had another decent review for about, I don't know, six or seven films.
But now you read about them and they're, they're, they're.
cult classics, you know.
What?
也就是所谓的经典之作。这，嗯，你知道，这很有趣。你知道，我不觉得我们拍过哪部电影——《美人鱼》的评价很好。而且在那之后的六七部电影里，我好像再没得到过什么像样的评价。但现在你去看关于它们的评论，它们都成了邪典经典，你知道的。什么？
They're a cult classic?
No, geez.
Didn't happen back in the day.
But once Philadelphia happened, I would imagine some of the scripts that were coming to you started to confuse things for you and your team a big.
Well, I got older.
You know, that's the other thing, too.
You know, there's a type of movie you can make in your late 20s.
I turned, here's a story.
它们成了邪典经典？不，天哪。当年可没有这种待遇。但自从《费城故事》之后，我想象你和你的团队接到的那些剧本，开始让你和团队感到有点困惑了。嗯，我变老了。你知道，这也是另一个原因。你知道，有些类型的电影只有在你快30岁时才能拍。我迎来了——这里有个故事：
I turned 27 the day of we wrapped the motion picture,
It was the last day of shooting.
We were in the Bahamas.
We had a cake that was actually for the rap.
Hey, let's celebrate the last day of shooting with a cake.
And someone, I think, with a tube of toothpaste, added in icing on the cake,
happy birthday, Tom, because they found out it was my birthday.
So that was, you know, there's a movie that you make when you're 27 and in your early 30s and whatnot and happened.
我满27岁的那天正好拍完那部电影，那是拍摄的最后一天。我们在巴哈马。我们甚至准备了一个蛋糕，其实是为了庆祝杀青。“嘿，我们用一个蛋糕来庆祝杀青的最后一天吧。”然后有人，我想是用一管牙膏，在蛋糕上用糖霜写上了“祝汤姆生日快乐”，因为他们发现那天刚好是我的生日。所以那就是，你知道的，有些电影是你27岁、30岁出头的时候拍的，诸如此类的事情就发生了。
And, you know, I made a number of them in which, but you have to get older.
You know, you can't...
Yeah.
And I was able to age into...
Gary Marshall gave me a great role with Jackie Gleason
in a movie called Nothing in Common.
And then David Seltzer wrote and directed with Sally Field,
a punchline, and then Big came along.
而且，你知道的，我拍过不少那样的电影，但你必须得变老。你知道，你不能……对。而我也顺理成章地到了那个年纪……加里·马歇尔给了我一个很棒的角色，让我和杰克·格里ソン一起出演了一部叫《小鞋匠》的电影。接着大卫·塞尔泽和莎莉·菲尔德一起编导了《一鸣惊人》，然后《飞越未来》就来了。
That's great, yeah.
But you get older, and so...
And you start singing, I will tell you...
Look, I'm not big on this kind of stuff,
but there was one time I was sitting around with my crack showbiz expert
who works for...
for CAA.
And he said to me,
太棒了，对。但人会变老，所以……而且你开始思考，我得告诉你……听着，我其实不太喜欢这种类型的事，但有一次我和我那个专门为CAA工作的顶尖娱乐圈专家坐在一起。他对我说：
what do you want to do?
And I said, you know, I...
Sounds exactly like Richard.
That's a great impersonation.
Richard love it. There you go.
Beautiful in person.
What do you want to do?
And I said, I said, I want to play grown-ups.
“你想做什么？”我说，你知道，我……听起来太像理查德了。模仿得太棒了。理查德·罗伯特。就是这样。模仿得真传神。“你想做什么？”我说，我说，我想演成年人。
I want to play people who have been through bitter compromise
because I was in my mid-30s by that point.
Compromise, Jason, is a thing that people do.
Yeah, when you hear the other person's side,
and then you go, okay, I'm willing to shift my position a little bit.
Whatever. We'll talk about it later when Tully's gone.
Sorry, Tom.
Wait, Tom, you know what I was wanted to ask you?
我想演那些经历过痛苦妥协的人，因为我当时已经三十岁中期了。妥协，杰森，是人们常做的事。是的，当你听到对方的观点，然后你说：“好吧，我愿意稍微调整一下我的立场。随便吧。等图利走了我们再聊这个。”抱歉，汤姆。等等，汤姆，你知道我一直想问你什么吗？
And this is going to be the dumbest question in the world.
Guaranteed.
He is the host, latest in Jim.
In Castaway, right?
You, the volleyball is named Wilson.
Now, you're married to the wonderful Rita Wilson, who I love, I adore, we all do.
Was that by design because it could have been called Spalding?
Jesus.
而且这绝对是世界上最蠢的问题。百分之百是的。他就是主持人，最新一期的吉姆。在《荒岛余生》里，对吧？你，那个排球叫威尔逊。现在，你娶了了不起的丽塔·威尔逊，我很爱她，我很崇拜她，我们大家都爱她。这是刻意安排的吗？因为这排球本来也可以叫斯伯丁啊？天哪。
Could have been.
It was written by Bill Broil.
and that
man
that movie took about six years to figure out
Bill Broils and I started talking about it
and we weren't shooting it until six years later
and he came up with the idea of a volleyball
完全有可能。那是比尔·布罗尔斯写的，而那部电影花了大约六年时间才构思成熟。比尔·布罗尔斯和我开始讨论它，直到六年之后我们才真正开始拍摄，他想出了一个排球的点子，
and he named it Wilson in honor of my beautiful bride
we've been married to it will be 34 years
in next day.
Hold for applause.
Yeah, good for you.
So no, it could have been
and I think we added the job.
并把它命名为“威尔逊”，以此来向我美丽的妻子致敬。我们结婚——到明天就满34年了。掌声有请。掌声有请。是的，真为你高兴。所以，不，它本来也可以叫别的，而且我想我们还加了那场戏。
There you go.
Thank you.
Well, Jesus Christ, that is a whole new level.
I'm like Fred.
I'm like Fred on Stern.
This is...
Now, you know, but it brings me to Finch.
Finch seems like it's got some qualities.
好了，给你。谢谢。好吧，天哪，这简直是另一个高度了。我简直像弗雷德。我就像霍华德·斯特恩节目里的弗雷德。这……现在，你知道的，但这让我想到了《芬奇》。《芬奇》似乎具备了一些特质。
I mean, if I was a hack studio executive, I'd say,
it's castaway meets Martian.
All movies are like that now.
Yeah.
Aren't they all, since you let you take a...
I suppose, yes.
This is on the waterfront meets pal joey by way of paw patrol.
我的意思是，如果我是一个唯利是图的电影厂高管，我就会说：“这简直是《荒岛余生》遇上《火星救援》。”现在的电影全都是这个调调。现在的电影全都是这个调调。是的。难道不是吗？自从你让大家……我想是的。这简直就是《码头风云》遇上《爵士乐手》再杂糅了《汪汪队立大功》。
Their own movies are a long on pop.
But what you need is a relatable, every man that is empathetic, sympathetic, can alpha and beta inside a page?
I mean, you are the man that could service all things.
I came up through that era of which every genre movie was about somebody who could not be killed or defeated, you know, the cop that could not be filled.
I'm with you.
the fighter who never lost.
And so, you know, a geeky guy with a big butt,
a big nose, and a squeaky voice.
它们自己的电影根本没啥深度。但你需要的是一个能引发共鸣的“凡人”主角，他既能让人感同身受，又能同时展现出强势和随和的一面？我的意思是，你就是那个能胜任所有类型的人。我是从那个年代走过来的，当时的每部类型片都是关于那种打不死、击不倒的角色，你知道的，永远不会被干掉的警察。我懂你的意思。永远不会输的拳击手。所以，你知道的，一个有点书呆子气、大屁股、大鼻子、声音尖细的家伙，
I took all the jobs away from Will.
By the way, I do have a big,
I have what's called a pro-dumper.
Well, you can't drive a spike with a tack hammer,
as I have heard.
Wait, I just have a really quick castaway story
that we might cut out of this.
And Tom, I think I told you this,
我把威尔的所有工作都抢光了。顺便说一句，我确实有一个很大的，我有一个所谓的“专业大屁股”。好吧，就像我听说过的那句话，“你不能用小锤子去砸大钉子”。等等，我这里有一个关于《荒岛余生》的超短小故事，我们甚至可能会把它从剪辑里删掉。汤姆，我想我跟你说过这个，
but I was working on Will and Grace with somebody who worked on the show
and we went to his house after a taping one night
and we got super, super, super, super stoned and Will knows this time.
This won't be cut.
Yeah, we had super, super, super, super stone.
And he said, look, I got a copy of Castaway.
I got the DVD.
Let's fast forward it to the plane crash
但我当时在《威尔和格蕾丝》剧组和一个剧组工作人员合作，有一天晚上录制结束后我们去了他家，然后我们抽大麻抽得嗨到飞起，威尔知道这事。这段不会被剪掉的。对，我们当时嗨到不能自拔。他说：“听着，我有一份《荒岛余生》的拷贝。我有DVD。我们直接快进到飞机失事那段吧，”
because the effects are so crazy.
Let's get totally high and watch.
Like, how do they do that, right?
And so he just moved in this house.
It was this brand new equipment
and I'm sitting in the back of his screening room
and he's up front.
He just moved into this crazy house.
“因为特效太疯狂了。我们彻底嗨起来看吧。他们到底是怎么做出来的？”对吧。所以他刚搬进这座房子。这是一套全新的设备，我坐在他放映室的最后面，他在最前面。他刚搬进这个疯狂的房子里。
It's gorgeous and he had no idea
how his own equipment worked.
So he's sitting in the back seat
and he can't get the DVD to play
and I said, oh no, is that a Sony?
Totally high out of my mind.
I go, is that a Sony?
He goes, yeah, I go, oh, their voice activated.
房子美极了，但他根本不知道自己的设备怎么用。所以他坐在后排，死活放不出DVD，我说：“哦，天哪，那是索尼的吗？”我当时已经嗨到神志不清了。我说：“那是索尼的吗？”他说：“对。”我说：“噢，那是声控的。”
Those are the new ones.
You don't even know what you have.
You have to speak the name of the movie
into the machine after you put it in.
He goes, what are you talking about?
I go, just listen to me.
You have to say the name.
name of the movie as you put it into the DVD player.
“那是最新款。你根本不知道自己买的是什么。你把碟放进去之后，必须对着机器说出电影的名字。”他说：“你在说什么？”我说：“听我的。你必须把电影的名字说出来，”
He's like, are you serious? I go 100%. I just read about
these. So he turns back to the machine with his back to me and he goes,
cast away.
And it didn't play and he waited a beat and they did it again. He goes,
And he turned behind me. I couldn't breathe. I was laughing.
So cruel.
It's one of my.
“然后把它塞进DVD播放器里。”他问：“你是认真的吗？”我说：“百分之百。我刚看过这方面的报道。”于是他转过身去面对机器，背对着我，大喊道：“荒岛余生。”结果没播放，他等了一拍，然后又试了一次。他喊道：“荒岛余生。”接着他转过身看着我。我都快喘不过气了。我笑得不行。太损了。这是我……
Bob Demetka's on that, he never cuts to the outside.
of the plane. That's one of the reasons why that
plane crashes is good.
It's so cool. Just from the perspective
of inside the plane. No, no eye
God kind of stuff there. That's Bob.
Now, Tom, with all of your
incredible set experience, was that
罗伯特·泽米吉斯在拍那场戏时，镜头从来没有切到飞机外面。这也是那场飞机失事拍得那么好的原因之一。太酷了。完全是从飞机内部的视角出发。不搞什么上帝视角那一套。这就是罗伯特。话说回来，汤姆，凭借你所有那些不可思议的片场经验，那是不是
what drew you, was it part of what drew you
to the director's chair? Just the
effort to sort of streamline
things because you knew
probably more than a lot of the directors
you may have been working with? No, I think
directing that becomes
sort of a bit of an ego thing because you become convinced that you know more than you actually do.
吸引你走向导演椅的原因之一？仅仅是为了让事情变得更顺畅，因为你懂得的可能比你合作过的很多导演还要多？不，我觉得当导演有时候有点自我膨胀的成分，因为你会开始确信自己懂得比实际上的要多。
But seriously.
But then you try it and you're like, oh my God, this is hard.
I believe every actor should direct.
I think every director should have to act.
I think we should all be writing and producing because you find out how hard it is to do that other job.
For sure.
From an actor's perspective, it's like, you know, you got somebody saying, uh, that was pretty
good, try it again. And you want to say
但说真的。不过等你真正去尝试了，你就会想：“天哪，这太难了。”我认为每个演员都应该去当导演。我觉得每个导演都应该去演演戏。我觉得我们都应该去写作和制片，因为只有这样你才会发现做另一份工作有多难。确实如此。从演员的角度来看，就像是，你知道的，有人对你说：“嗯，刚才那条挺不错的，再来一条。”而你心里很想对他说：
to him, do you realize I'm
on a horse
weeping because my dog died
and I'm trying
to remember six pages of dialogue
at the same? Do you realize
it's a little harder than it is?
Man, let's try it again.
“你难道没看到我正骑在马上哭丧着脸，因为我的狗死了，而且我同时还得记住六页的台词吗？你难道没意识到这比看起来要难一点吗？”“老兄，我们再试一条吧。”
That, along with the same thing of an actor saying,
hey, we're going to shoot this or what? Are we
shooting or what? Right. You have
to realize everybody has
nine million things going on inside
their head. And also, well, look,
We're all storytellers.
At some point, we can have a sense of what might fit into our mouths a little bit better and maybe some options.
这和演员说的话如出一辙：“嘿，我们什么时候拍这个？还是说不拍了？”对吧？你必须意识到，每个人脑子里都有九百万件事在同时运转。而且，好吧，听着，我们都是讲故事的人。在某种程度上，我们能感觉到什么样的台词更适合从我们嘴里说出来，也许我们能提供一些不同的选择。
It goes back to the thing Dan Sullivan always said, which have an idea in your pocket.
You know, have something that you can come out and say, this isn't on the page, but let me show you something else here.
So since you have directed, when you do come to the set as an actor with an idea in your pocket,
are you sensitive to that there might actually be a plan in place that that director and that crew has been working on?
for weeks and that your idea might
disassemble the House of Cards?
There might not be room for it.
So then you try it once and they say
这就回到了丹·沙利文常说的那句话：在口袋里揣个主意。你知道的，得准备点什么，随时能站出来说：“剧本上虽然没写这个，但我来给你展示点别的。”所以，既然你当过导演，当你作为演员带着“口袋里的主意”来到片场时，你会不会很敏感地意识到，其实导演和剧组已经制定好了一个他们已经筹备了几个星期的拍摄计划，而你的主意可能会让整座纸牌屋轰然倒塌？可能根本没有空间让你发挥。所以你试了一次，他们说
don't do that and so and then you don't do it.
You know, it's pretty relatively easy stuff.
Is that desire to direct still burning in you?
I can't say that I have the instinctive powers
of being a director as an actor.
I think I know what I want to do.
I read it and I say, oh, I know what direction I'll go to.
directing is a
“别这么演”，然后你就真的不这么演了。你知道的，这其实挺简单的。那种想当导演的渴望现在还在你心中燃烧吗？我不能说我作为一个演员具备当导演的本能天赋。我觉得我知道自己想拍成什么样。我读到剧本就会想：“噢，我知道我会往哪个方向拍。”但导演工作是一项
directing requires a fidelity and a patience
and an ability to communicate.
After I've done it,
I've directed two feature films.
I've directed a number of episodes
of the miniseries that we've done,
and I like those because I wrote them,
more I wrote on them at the same time.
导演工作需要极大的忠诚度、耐以及沟通能力。自我尝试之后——我导演过两部故事片，还导演过我们制作的迷你剧中的好几集，我挺喜欢那些的，因为剧本是我写的，而且我当时也参与了编剧工作。
But I think directors more so
than myself's an actor,
they're born.
into it. You know, you have to think it's the greatest job in the world. Yeah. And oftentimes it's not.
Yeah. Do you enjoy the producing part of it all with what you guys...
I don't really produce. Well, but you guys churn out, it's really, you shouldn't sluff over it.
It's the alliances that I make with other people that really do all the work.
But the amount of, you're incredibly prolific as a producer, you and Gary at play, Tony.
但我认为导演们，比起我这种兼职演员，他们简直是天生吃这碗饭的。你知道的，你必须认为这是世界上最棒的工作。是的。但通常情况并非如此。是的。你喜欢你们团队在幕后制作的那部分工作吗？我其实不怎么当制片人。好吧，但你们产出的作品量惊人，真的，你不能轻描淡写地带过。那是我和别人建立的联盟，真正干活的是他们。但是，作为制片人，你的多产程度令人难以置信，你和加里在Playtone公司，
I mean, it's, it's, you've employed an incredible amount of people. You've put a lot of product out there.
that's not easy and that's incredibly admirable.
Well, I'm very lucky because we have extremely good people.
And we do this, you know, we have a kind of like a clubhouse office
where we lean in each other's doorway and say, you know,
is this really a feature film, guys?
I'm not so sure it's a feature film.
Shouldn't it be like a 12-part mini-series instead
我的意思是，你们雇用了数量惊人的员工。你们推出了大量作品，这可绝非易事，而且极其令人钦佩。嗯，我非常幸运，因为我们有一群极其优秀的员工。而且我们做这件事的方式，你知道的，我们有一种类似俱乐部式的办公室，我们会把头探进彼此的门口问：“嘿，这真的适合拍成故事片吗，伙计们？我不太确定这能不能撑起一部故事片。难道不应该把它拍成12集的迷你剧吗？
so we can really examine the theme?
And then you make nothing but a ton of alliances.
But here's, I'm not a producer because,
this is what producers do every day.
They get on the phone
and they try to convince somebody
to do something they do not want to do.
Or they tell somebody on the phone
这样我们才能真正深入探讨这个主题。”然后你就顺理成章地缔造了无数的合作关系。但话说回来，我并不是个真正的制片人，因为——制片人每天都在做这些事。他们拿起电话，试图说服别人去做他们根本不想做的事。或者他们在电话里告诉别人
that there's no way
that they are going to do
what that person on the phone really wants.
That's pretty much it.
It's that dichotomy.
I always just say, sure,
no matter what they're saying.
We'll be right back.
对方绝对不可能实现电话那头提出的要求。差不多就是这样。就是这种两面性。不管别人说什么，我总是满口答应：“没问题。”我们马上回来。
And now back to the show.
Let me ask you how, how, what, what's your feeling about this, this transition that we're all in into a bit more of a streaming element, uh, married with, uh, you know, box office, you know, theatrical, you know, going to the theater paying and paying some money for a ticket versus having it at home?
Do you, um, what is your opinion on that as somebody, uh, in the business and then also as somebody who is a, who is a viewer?
Is it, is it, do you like the fact that there is less pressure now, maybe?
with not having to open on the weekend because it's streaming.
Do you think about that?
Well, that's a pressure that doesn't come upon the actor because, look, the movies are always binary.
They're either double zero or zero one.
欢迎回到节目。我想问你，对于我们所有人正在经历的这场向流媒体的转型，以及它与票房、院线电影——也就是去电影院买票看电影——相结合的现状，你有什么感受？比起在家里看，作为一个业内人士以及一个观众，你对此有何看法？你是不是觉得，由于流媒体的存在，不用再背负首周末票房的压力了，所以现在压力变小了，你喜欢这种改变吗？你会去想这些吗？嗯，这种压力其实并不会降临到演员头上，因为，听着，电影永远是二元的。它们要么是双零，要么是零一。
They either work or they do not work.
And if they don't work, there's no amount of marketing or interviews that you can do on podcasts.
In order to change the zeitgeist, the pressure remains absolute.
The pressure is the speed of light
in order to make a great story.
The audience, I think, if I can pontificate
just a little bit here,
doesn't care where they see it.
要么大卖，要么扑街。如果扑街了，你花再多的营销费用或者在播客里做再多的采访，都无济于事。要想改变时代精神，压力依然是绝对的。为了讲出一个伟大的故事，这种压力就像光速一样快。观众——如果允许我在这里稍微高谈阔论一下的话——才不在乎他们是在哪里看电影的。
The business does.
The marketing, the producers,
and the studios, and the grand entertainment
industrial complex, you know,
they would like things to be exactly as they were,
but we have a business that is forever changing.
You know, back in 1980,
when you guys were still in junior high school,
商业资本在乎。营销人员、制片人、电影厂以及庞大的娱乐工业复合体，你知道的，他们希望一切都维持原样，但我们身处一个永远在变化的行业中。你知道，早在1980年，当你们还在读初中时，
and the concept of home video was just beginning.
Here's a story that goes back a long way.
When we were, the first year that Peter and I were in bosom buddies,
a VHS tape machine, a player at home, cost about $4,000.
Yeah.
Wow.
And the only people that had them were incredibly wealthy, rich people.
Three-quarter inch, right, too, weren't that?
家庭录像带的概念才刚刚萌芽。这里有个尘封已久的故事。当时，彼得和我合作《同志亦凡人》的第一年，一台VHS录像带播放机在家里要卖大约4000美元。是的。哇。而且只有极其富有的人才买得起。当时还是四分之三英寸磁带，对吧？
Well, by that time, VHS was just beginning.
And in a neighborhood, maybe a guy named Doug would open up Doug's video rental shop, S-H-O-P-P-E.
Old-timey video shopping.
And on one side of the rental space would be VHS tapes,
and on the other side would be a smaller collection of beta, Sony Beta Max.
And eventually, beta went away, and it was all just VHS.
And by the time, I think the next year VHS machines were only like $1,800.
And then everybody was renting.
嗯，到了那个时候，VHS才刚开始普及。在某个社区里，可能有个叫道格的家伙会开一家“道格录像带租赁店”。老式的录像带商店。租赁区的一边摆着VHS录像带，另一边则是一个小得多的索尼Betamax录像带专区。最后，Beta淘汰了，到处都成了VHS的天下。到了第二年，我想VHS录像带播放机降到了1800美元左右。然后每个人都在租带子看。
And the concept that you could, it was great, of course, to be able to record shows after you went through this arcane kind of like process of on, off, recording, timing up.
But the bigger thing was, is that if you had kids and you had a VHS of Dumbo, you know, they would get up in the morning on their own and put in Dumbo.
and you didn't have to get up.
This was huge.
And here we are in 2021,
and the industry is going through something akin to that change,
because guess what?
As Gary Getsman, my partner at Playtone said,
你可以录制节目的概念——当然，前提是你得经历那种繁琐的开关机、定时操作——这真的很棒。但更重要的一点是，如果你有孩子，而且你手里有一盘《小飞象》的VHS录像带，你知道的，他们早上会自己起床把《小飞象》放进机器里，
you know, sitting at home and watching something on your TV
is not that bad.
Right, right, right.
You know, Tom, you said to me years ago,
you said, you know what, Sean, the business is always changing,
and you have to adapt and change with it.
Not as an actor or the craft of creating things,
just you have to keep an open mind
而你根本不用起床。这简直太棒了。而现在我们来到了2021年，整个行业正在经历类似于那次变革的巨变，因为你猜怎么着？正如我在Playtone的合伙人加里·格茨曼所说，
and go with the flow of it.
Otherwise, and if you fight it, you're just dead in the water.
But why didn't you take that advice?
Why didn't you do it?
Yeah, what happened there, Sean?
Because now you're reduced to hosting the Heartless podcast.
Is it Heartless?
It's Heartless.
坐在家里看电视上播放的内容，其实也没那么糟。对，对，对。你知道，汤姆，你多年前曾对我说过，你说：“你知道吗，肖恩，这个行业一直在变，你必须去适应它并随之改变。”不是作为演员或创作本身，而是你必须保持开放的心态，
You're known as Dumbo, the host of Heartless.
We were very lucky.
We were very lucky at Playtone because one of our first deals was at HBO,
and this was old-school.
HBO. You know, no commercials. You could say anything you wanted to. There was no language. There was no, there was no, and at that point, HBO doing so doing a series or a movie or a miniseries on HBO, that was the gold standard.
Yeah, it seemed as though you had all the freedom in the world. And now you have even more of that, all the freedom in the world. But it still comes down to this very basic requirement. You've got to be putting out an awfully good product. Otherwise it will disappear into the mist. Like, no.
many of my early films.
Thanks, guys.
顺应潮流。否则，如果你去抗拒它，你就会彻底完蛋。但你为什么不听取这个建议呢？你为什么自己没做到呢？是的，肖恩，这是怎么回事？因为你现在沦落到主持《冷血无情》播客了。是叫《冷血无情》吗？是《冷血无情》。
No, no, no, no.
But how have you not...
I'm surprised,
because it seems like they've tried
to gobble up everybody.
How have you not...
When did Marvel call you and say,
Tom, we need you to play, you know,
你现在被称为“小飞象”，《冷血无情》的主持人。我们当时非常幸运。我们在Playtone非常幸运，因为我们的第一笔交易之一就是和HBO合作，那是老派的HBO。你知道的，没有商业广告。你想说什么就能说什么。没有任何限制。没有……而且在那时，在HBO制作一个系列剧、电影或迷你剧，那就是行业内的黄金标准。是的，当时看起来你拥有全世界所有的自由。而现在你拥有了更多那样的自由，全世界所有的自由。但它最终仍然归结于一个最基础的要求：你必须拿出极其优秀的作品。否则它就会消失在迷雾之中。就像……
Dr. Universe,
and, you know, we need you to do 12 films
and you have to play Doctor Universe.
Did that ever happen?
Here's the problem.
First of all, they've never called me once.
I can't believe that.
No, no.
我的许多早期电影一样。谢谢你们，伙计们。不，不，不，不。但是你怎么能……我很惊讶，因为感觉他们试图吞并所有人。你怎么会……漫威什么时候给你打电话说：“汤姆，我们需要你来演，你知道的，”
never and I think that if one of these days they will and they'll say is there any way you would
consider playing the secretary of defense a guy who comes and says please help us all for man we can't
we can't survive I'll be one of those guys I don't get to play the punk confluence but god
god bless you because you still make the kinds of films you have continued in an era where
where most features are, you know,
the feature film market is dominated
by these huge...
Some of those are great.
“宇宙博士，我们需要你拍12部电影，你必须扮演宇宙博士。”这种事发生过吗？问题就在这里。首先，他们从来没给我打过一次电话。我简直不敢相信。不，不，
Some of those are a blast.
No, no, I'm saying they're great, and I have a lot of friends
who do them and who make them.
Well, they're not all great, but some of them are really...
I said some. I said some, but some of them are good,
and we all have friends who we adore
and who are super talented who make those.
I'm not saying that.
从来没有。我觉得总有一天他们会打来的，他们会说：“你有没有考虑过演国防大臣？就是那种跑出来说‘求求大家救救人类吧，我们撑不下去了’的角色。”我会去演那种角色，我演不了核心主角，但上帝保佑你们，因为你们依然在制作各种各样的电影，在绝大多数故事片市场都被那些庞大的巨制统治的时代里，你们依然在坚持……其中有些真的很棒。
But there is, it seems like a shrinking market
for films that stand on their own
because it's a great story and has a great
cast and blah, blah, and you seem to be one of those people.
You're in a very unique position that you're still making those films, which I think is awesome.
We chastised.
We chastised JJ Abrams.
We were like, go and make some comedies, JJ.
有些简直爽爆了。不，不，我是说它们很棒，我有很多朋友就在拍这些电影。好吧，也不是全都那么棒，但有些确实……我说了“有些”。我说了“有些”，但有些确实很好，而且我们都有那些我们深爱且超级有才华的朋友在拍这些。我不是那个意思。
You know, we were giving him shit.
He wants to.
But, you know, it's because, Tom, because Tom, you are us and you have maintained being us.
You, as for as famous and as successful as you have become for as long as you have been, you have still.
stayed very grounded, it seems, and normal.
And I would imagine that that is just something you're stuck with
from when you were a little kid
and you've probably got a couple of parents to thank for that, I would imagine.
但似乎那种能够独立成篇的电影的市场在不断缩小，因为它们单靠一个伟大的故事、强大的演员阵容等等就能立足，而你似乎就是那种人。你处于一个非常独特的地位，你依然在制作那些电影，我觉得这太酷了。我们曾严厉批评过J·J·艾布拉姆斯。我们当时对他说：“去拍点喜剧吧，J·J。”
My parents divorced when I was five years old, guys.
Way to go, Jason.
Way to fucking go.
This is why I'm not getting the nominations.
This is where Sean really does his research.
He would know that.
Tom, I don't know this.
What did your folks think about you getting into the business tree, as I call it?
你知道的，我们当时没少损他。他其实很想拍。但是，你知道的，那是因为，汤姆，因为汤姆，你就是我们中的一员，而且你一直保持着我们普通人的本色。无论你变得多么出名、多么成功，维持了多久的名气，你依然
You know, I started doing it for fun in high school
because I couldn't believe that you could go and do plays in high school
and get credit for it.
You know, this is school.
I remember specifically thinking that the first time I walked into a drama class.
And I did it because some friends of mine from junior high had been in the plays.
And I just said, what?
I can come to school and do this?
保持得非常脚踏实地，表现得就像个正常人。我想这一定是因为你从小到大一直保持着这种特质，你大概得感谢你的父母吧，我想。我的父母在我五岁时就离婚了，伙计们。干得漂亮，杰森。他妈的干得太漂亮了。这就是为什么我拿不到提名。这就是肖恩真正做功课的地方。他本来该知道这一点的。汤姆，我真不知道这个。你的父母对你进入“演艺圈”——我这么叫它——是什么看法？
Well, this is screwing around, man.
This is goofing off in class.
I felt the exact same way.
I was like, oh, my God, everybody's just laughing.
This is great.
Both my dad and eventually my mom,
because we lived in different places.
When my mom came and saw me and stuff,
你知道的，我一开始在高中演戏纯粹是为了好玩，因为我简直不敢相信你居然可以在高中演话剧还能拿学分。你知道的，这可是学校啊。我清楚地记得第一次走进戏剧教室时，脑子里就是这么想的。我之所以去演，是因为初中的几个朋友参加过话剧演出，我当时就说：“什么？我可以来学校做这个？”
they just thought, well, this is just wonderful.
Look what Tommy found.
Sean, you've talked about that.
You just said it.
You had that same thing, right,
where you were like, this is amazing.
This is so much fun, and I can't believe I get to do this at five, six, seven, eight.
And then hit it, Sean.
“这简直是在胡闹嘛，老兄。这简直就是在课堂上偷懒。”我当时的感觉完全一样。我心想：“噢，天哪，每个人都在笑。这太棒了。”我爸，以及后来的我妈——因为我们住在不同地方。当我妈来看我演戏之类的时候，
Hey, now, Sean, when you did, you did promises, promises on.
Thank you, everybody.
He's never brought it up.
That's weird.
He's never mentioned it.
And it was a big hit.
And you said something to me, because Sean and I see each other.
Socially.
他们只会觉得：“噢，这真是太棒了。看看汤姆找到了什么。”肖恩，你聊过这个。你刚才自己也说过了。你当时也有那种感觉，对吧？你当时觉得：“这太惊人了。这太好玩了，我简直不敢相信我在五岁、六岁、七岁、八岁的时候就能做这个。”然后就接上了，肖恩。
Not just on this podcast.
So after you had done promises promises,
and it was huge because you played the piano.
on stage and you did all this stuff.
It was a big Broadway hit, right?
A number of years ago.
And I said, are you going to do it again?
Do you have the desire to get up
嘿，现在，肖恩，当你在演……你演过《承诺，承诺》……谢谢大家。他从来没提过这事。真奇怪。他从来没提过。而且那是一部大热剧。你当时对我说过一些话，因为肖恩和我经常见面。
and do another Broadway show?
And you said something that was,
I swear to God,
the only person I heard make the same sort of reference.
Are you ready for this?
I read it as a quote from Lawrence Olivier.
You said, I'm not sure I have the fire in the belly.
Yes.
不仅仅是在这个播客里。所以在你演完《承诺，承诺》之后，那部戏火得一塌糊涂，因为你在舞台上弹钢琴，做了各种各样的表演。那是一部百老汇大热门剧，对吧？那是好几年前的事了。我问你：“你还会再演吗？你还有没有那种冲动去”
in order to get up and do eight performances or something.
I remember when Lawrence Olivier was older,
and he was always asked, well, will you ever get up at the national again?
What having?
He says, no, because it requires a stronger heart.
And he wasn't talking about medically.
He was talking about all the effort that goes in the fire in the belly.
Well, Sean, because you would do eight shows a week.
“再演一部百老汇戏剧？”你当时说了一句让我发誓——唯一一个让我听到过做过类似引用的人。你准备好了吗？我读到过劳伦斯·奥利维尔的一句名言。你当时说：“我不确定我心里还有没有那团火。”是的。
I remember we've talked a lot about promises, promises.
But you said some of the same, you were like,
I do it, you did it for nine months or a year?
How long did you do it for?
A year.
Remember you saying, similar thing that you said to Tom, you said the same thing.
I said, would you do it again?
“为了连着演八场或者别的什么演出。”我记得劳伦斯·奥利维尔年纪大了以后，总有人问他：“噢，你还会回国家剧院演出吗？感觉怎么样？”他说：“不，因为那需要更强大心脏。”他说的不是医学意义上的心脏。他说的是支撑这一切所需的精力——也就是心里的那团火。好吧，肖恩，因为你以前一周得演八场演出。
And you said, I don't know if I have it in me.
Yeah.
Five, six, seven, eight.
And then you just went right to.
No, no, it's true, Tom.
You know, because I relayed that to you about the constant work ethic you have to jump from movie to movie to movie to movie.
movie over these decades and they're all great and their and your work like Jason said it's always
fantastic you always committed you're always in it and and I switch that that question back to you
我记得我们讨论过很多关于《承诺，承诺》的事。但你也说过类似的话，你当时说——你演了九个月还是一年？你演了多久？一年。整整一年。我记得你说过类似的话，跟汤姆说的话差不多，你也说过：“我不知道自己体内还有没有那种能量。”五、六、七、八。然后你直接就……不，不，这是真的，汤姆。你知道的，因为我曾把这个转达给你，关于你那种必须在几十年里从一部电影接一部电影、一部电影接一部电影地不断拍下去的工作精神，
about filmmaking is do you still have the fire in the belly to travel and get up at five and
stay in this hotel and that hotel and and and you said yeah because it's what it's what I love to do and
yeah I do yeah there's no other way of
putting it.
There is, look, it's more fun than fun.
That was something that I learned a long time ago
before I got my job at the Great Lake, Shakespeare.
Work in the theater is more fun than fun.
而且它们全都很棒，正如杰森所说，你的作品总是那么出色，你总是全情投入，你总是融入其中。我把那个问题抛回给你，关于电影创作：“你心里是否依然保留着那团火，去四处奔波，早上五点起床，住这家酒店又住那家酒店，并且……”而你说：“是的，因为这是我热爱的事，我的确有，是的。”没有别的更好的说法了。这里面，听着，这比好玩还要好玩。那是很久以前我还没在五大湖莎士比亚剧团找到工作时就学到的道理。在剧院工作比好玩还要好玩。
And I thought, well, yeah, this is a great way to spend your day.
It's not just a lifestyle or, you know, life's work.
It's a life.
I love that.
And now, listen, out of all of your entire repertoire, all of your credits, is there one movie...
He's going to ask you, what is your favorite movie?
Jesus Christ.
No, no, no.
当时我想：“噢，是的，这是度过一整天的好方法。”这不仅仅是一种生活方式或终身事业。这就是生活。我太喜欢这个概念了。现在，听听看，在你所有的作品中，在你所有的演艺履历里，有没有哪部电影……他要问你最喜欢的电影是什么了。天哪，不，不，不。
is there one movie or experience
that was extra special to you
that will always stick in your brain?
You know, I will say, look,
yes, they all are in so many ways.
Look, I've never had a rotten time making a movie.
I've always come away from a movie saying,
I can't believe they pay me to do this.
有没有哪部电影或哪段经历对你来说格外特别，永远铭刻在你的脑海里？你知道，我会说，听着，是的，从很多方面来说全都是这样。听着，我拍电影从来没有过糟糕的经历。我每次拍完电影离开时都会想：“我简直不敢相信他们居然花钱让我做这个。”
That was fantastic.
Despite the discomforts in the 5 in the morning,
a little harder at the age of 65, I guess.
But the experience of making the movie,
that thing you do.
I cast it with a bunch of friends.
We had a great time.
It was the beginning of the company that I formed.
“太棒了。”尽管早上五点起床会有身体上的不适，到了65岁这个年纪确实感觉更吃力了一点。但拍电影的经历本身，你所做的那些事。我找了一群朋友来出演。我们度过了一段美好的时光。那是我成立的公司建立的开端。
So great. I love that movie.
With Gary Getsman and everybody else down at Playtone.
I could do that again and again and again.
Was that the first film you directed?
That was the first, not the first directing gig I had,
but it was the first feature film, yeah.
And it was, it had music in it,
and it was very personal because it was set in 1964,
太棒了。我太喜欢那部电影了。和加里·格茨曼以及Playtone的每一个人一起。我可以一遍又一遍地拍那个。那是你导演的第一部电影吗？那是第一部——不是我导演的第一部作品，但那是第一部故事片，是的。而且里面有音乐，非常个人化，因为故事设定在1964年，
for so it was uh but you know every every gig is uh magnificent the the ones that don't
that may be disappointed a little bit is the ones where you don't get to spend enough time doing it
like i was just uh i just did two weeks with west anderson in spain with the west
anderson repertory company and that was fantastic and i was bummed out he said oh we got to
leave we've shot out my role i got to i got to go now i'd like to like to linger for a little bit
I just got to do a couple days with our buddy Tyka, Y-T-T-T,
and it was just the greatest experience.
And then it was just, we did a show for HBO,
所以它带有……但是，你知道，每一次工作都是无与伦比的。那些可能会稍微让人有点失望的经历，就是你没有足够的时间去享受它，就像我刚刚……我刚刚和韦斯·安德森在西班牙拍了两周的戏，加入了韦斯·安德森的轮演剧团，那简直太棒了。结果我很沮丧，他说：“噢，我们得走了，你的戏份拍完了，我得走了，我得走了。”我还想多逗留一会儿呢。我刚和我们的老铁泰卡合作了几天，Y-T-T-T（指Taika Waititi），那简直是最棒的体验。然后就是，我们给HBO拍了一部剧，
and then I just did his movie.
And I was like, it was like the greatest, most fun month.
And then I'm like, oh, and it's over.
Yeah.
And that was, I just want to go and play with that gang.
Don't we get to have that 90-day experience here off somewhere, you know,
pounding something out and getting up and 11?
Well, you've given us not 90 days, but a solid hour of you.
然后我刚刚拍了他的电影。感觉就像是最棒、最有趣的一个月。然后我就想：“噢，这就结束了。”是的。而我只想去跟那帮人一起玩。难道我们就不能在哪里获得那种持续90天的体验，一起死磕某个项目，然后在11点起床吗？好吧，你给我们的虽然不是90天，但也是实打实的整整一个小时的陪伴。
your very, very valuable time.
Yes, thank you so much.
Thank you on behalf of these two fellow smartless folks,
as well as everyone in America and the world,
for providing us all these little worlds that you have created
that we all get to live in, and they've all been fantastic.
Is there a podcast award for second bananas or third bananas
that you, Jason, and Will might be up for?
你那非常非常宝贵的金钱时间。是的，非常感谢。我谨代表这两位聪明的Smartless伙计，以及全美和全世界的所有人，感谢你为我们创造了所有这些我们可以栖息的小世界，它们全都是那么棒。请问有没有什么播客奖项是颁给二号谐星或三号谐星的？你、杰森和威尔可能会去角逐一下？
Will and I are going to battle for that one.
You have to ask questions like, what's your favorite movie?
Yeah.
No, you've got a monopoly on that.
You got it all buttoned up.
I would say that in Canada, this is known as Will Arnett's Smartless.
That's true, it's true.
Wait, the number one podcast in Canada.
威尔和我为了这个要打一架了。你必须去问那种问题，比如“你最喜欢的电影是什么？”是的。不，你在这方面是垄断地位。你把一切都包揽了。我要说的是，在加拿大，这个节目被称为《威尔·阿奈特的Smartless》。确实如此，确实如此。等等，加拿大排名第一的播客。
I think I just got voted Canada's favorite son.
I'm not sure, but I'm putting it out there in case anybody wants to latch on to that and start making that a thing.
I'm happy to.
Well, it's a delight talking to you guys.
You too, Tom.
Thank you for saying yes to this.
The delight is ours.
Tom, I just, words don't express how I feel.
我想我刚刚被评为加拿大最受欢迎的儿子。我不确定，但我把它说出来，以防有人想抓住这个并开始把它变成现实。我很乐意。好吧，和你们聊天真令人高兴。你也是，汤姆。谢谢你答应接受这个。高兴的是我们。汤姆，我只是，言语无法表达我的感受。
I'm such a...
You're very kind, very kind, guys.
And listen, good luck on the...
Is there a name for this award yet?
It's the Iheart Radio Award.
The I Heart Radio Award.
It might be called the Aorta.
Who you up against?
我真是个……你们太好了，非常感谢，伙计们。听着，祝你们……这个奖有名字了吗？是IHeart电台奖。I Heart Radio奖。它可能叫主动脉奖。你们和谁竞争？
That would be a big question there.
Oh, that's a great question.
Hardcore history, maybe.
Up against hardcore history?
Sure.
Fingers crossed.
It's so great to see you.
Thanks, Tom, very much.
那将是一个大问题。哦，这是个好问题。也许是硬核历史（Hardcore History）。跟硬核历史竞争？当然。祈祷吧。很高兴见到你。谢谢你，汤姆，非常感谢。
Good to see you guys.
Hope to, well, we'll hang at all those places
that people like us end up at.
Yeah, for sure.
All right, take care of guys.
Bye, thank you, Tom.
All right, buddy.
A lot to love to you.
很高兴见到你们。希望，好吧，我们会去那些像我们这样的人最后都会去的地方闲逛。是的，当然。好的，保重，伙计们。再见，谢谢你，汤姆。好的，兄弟。非常爱你。
Bye, bye, Tom.
I think he's going to make it.
That guy's got some charisma.
Jason, let me just say this.
You've been complaining for a couple of you've been saying,
man, great guess you guys.
And then you just decided you pulled out at one of these,
what I've now referred to is,
再见，再见，汤姆。我想他会成功的。这家伙真有个人魅力。杰森，我只想说这个。你已经抱怨了好几个……你一直在说，天哪，你们的嘉宾真棒。然后你刚刚决定，你拿出了其中一个，我现在称之为，
because I don't use this word,
as the topper card.
I'm going to now call it the topper card.
He's that.
He's a blue chip, that one right there.
Oh, man, what a delight.
I mean, he's just like.
He does have that thing.
因为我不用这个词，把它叫做王牌。我现在要叫它王牌。他就是那样。他是个优质股，就是那个。哦，天哪，真高兴。我的意思是，他就像。他确实有那种特质。
I kept trying to figure out a way to ask him this without him deflecting as he does so well, so humbly.
And I just kind of bailed on it because I knew he just wouldn't.
Like, he's just got that.
He's, he is us.
He is completely personable and authentic.
He is, he's every bit a leader that you'd want him to be, but he doesn't seem like he's too arrogant or cocky to, like I don't know.
How does he?
You mean us as an audience?
我一直在想方设法问他这个问题，而又不让他像他平时那样巧妙而谦虚地转移话题。我只是有点放弃了，因为我知道他不会。就像，他身上有那种特质。他，他就是我们。他完全平易近人且真实。他绝对是你所希望的那种领导者，但他看起来又不会太傲慢或自大，以至于，我不知道。他是怎么做到的？你是说我们作为一个观众？
not that's three yes like he's just like he's the guy you want to follow and are never annoyed
you know watching him or i don't know it's it's been so consistent yeah i don't see myself as an
every man oh no you definitely no i see myself i'm special yeah well um i'm like the boss of the
every man you know so when i'm there when i see tom come in i'm like it's great spending time with
one of my employees.
I hope he keeps staying as prolific as he is.
I mean, he's doing, like, what, at least a film a year?
Same here.
不，那是三个“是”——就像他就是那种你想追随而且看他时绝不会觉得烦的人，或者我不知道，这太一致了。是的，我不觉得自己是个普通人。哦，不，你绝对……不，我觉得我很特别。是的，嗯……我是普通人的老板，你知道吗？所以当我在那里，当我看到汤姆进来时，我会觉得，和我的一个员工共度时光真是太棒了。我希望他能继续保持他目前的这种高产。我的意思是，他做的事，比如，什么，至少一年一部电影？我也是。
That's what I meant about the movies he makes.
I love that he keeps making movies that are like, it just seems like not a lot of other
people are making.
And his new movie, which we talked on, what is the, the Finch?
Yeah, Finch.
No, no, not The Finch.
Just Finch.
Finch.
这就是我说的他拍的那些电影的意思。我喜欢他一直拍的那种电影，感觉好像没有多少其他人还在拍。他的新电影，我们讨论过的，那个是什么，Finch？对，Finch。不，不，不是The Finch。就叫Finch。Finch。
The bird.
Yeah, Finch, it's on Apple, and it's basically...
When is it on Apple?
When is it?
It's not on now?
First week in November.
November 5th.
那只鸟。对，Finch，在苹果上播，它基本上是……什么时候在苹果上？什么时候？现在不在吗？十一月的第一周。十一月五号。十一月五号。
Yeah.
So he's doing this movie, Finch.
The sequel is going to be The Finch, I heard.
Yeah.
No, it's called Fincher.
It's called Fincher.
Oh, it's called Fincher.
十一月五号。是的。所以他拍了这部电影《Finch》。我听说续集要叫《The Finch》。是的。不，它叫《Fincher》。它叫Fincher。哦，它叫Fincher。
And David Fincher is directing it.
Yeah.
We're shooting it right now.
Are you kidding?
Dude, this is...
Showbiz is incredible.
I know.
It's everything is aligned.
大卫·芬奇在导演它。是的。我们现在正在拍摄。你在开玩笑吗？老兄，这个是……演艺圈太不可思议了。我知道。一切都对上了。
But it's him and a dog and a robot.
And this is not the start of a joke.
But could anybody pull off a high wire act like that?
But they do walk into a bar.
There is one bar.
They do walk into a bar, be fair.
In fairness, they walk in.
But I saw the trailer, too, with my almost 13-year-old,
但里面有他、一只狗和一个机器人。这不是一个笑话的开头。但是谁能完成那样的高空走钢丝表演呢？但他们确实走进了一家酒吧。确实有一家酒吧。说实话，他们确实走进去了。但我也看了预告片，和我快13岁的孩子一起，
and we watched it and looked at each other.
We're like, yeah, we'll watch that.
Yeah.
And don't you feel like he's kind of like our ambassador,
not just for the business and not just for Hollywood,
not just for Los Angeles, but like America, too?
Yes, absolutely.
He's like quintessentially American and, like.
我们看了，互相看了看。我们就像，好吧，我们会看那个。是的。难道你不觉得他有点像我们的形象大使，不仅为了商业，不仅为了好莱坞，不仅为了洛杉矶，而且也为了美国吗？是的，绝对的。他简直太美国化了，而且，像。
He's one of the few people we can, both sides, if you will, can agree on.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
What do you mean?
Wait, wait.
What's the other?
I just met like both.
Like, never mind.
他是我们少数几个双方，如果你愿意的话，都能达成一致的人之一。对。对，对。什么意思？等等，等等。另一个是什么？我只是指双方。算了吧。
Everybody in America can agree.
Oh, those most sides.
Yeah, LeShan, we are not political.
Sorry, so please.
What are you trying to do?
You're trying to lose your award?
You're trying to wade me into deep water
and then you're going to take me down like a crocodile
全美国的每个人都能达成一致。哦，那些双方。是的，勒尚，我们不谈政治。抱歉，所以请。你想干嘛？你想丢掉你的奖吗？你想把我拽进深水里，然后像鳄鱼一样把我按住
and keep me under?
Bye!
You can't fucking bail out like that.
You can't bail yourself out.
Yeah.
You can't be saved by your own bell.
We've used everyone.
把我压在下面？再见！再见！你不能他妈的就这样逃跑。你不能自己逃脱。是的。你不能被你自己的铃声拯救。我们已经用过了
word that you could do with buy no not at all no but also you were just trying to bail yourself out
of a sinking ship and you can't you can't use buy as a as a as a as some kind of you know instrument to
bail out your sinking ship why not i just did it yeah i guess you can't sorry there is no rule in that
you're right you can um but do you think that when he first moved oh oh no sorry
shun let's hear it come on go ahead
One of the questions I did get to here was, he was, in 1979, he made a move to New York City.
And he was trying to be an actor full-time.
So I wonder if he was just trying to take a bite out of the apple in 1979.
你可以用“再见”做成的每一个词。不，一点也不，不。但你也只是想从一艘下沉的船上逃跑，而你不能，你不能把“再见”当作某种，你知道的，用来逃离你下沉船只的工具。为什么不？我刚做了。是的，我想你不能。抱歉，这没有规则，你说得对，你可以。但是你觉得他刚搬来时，哦，哦，不，抱歉，顺，让我们听听，来吧，继续。我问过的一个问题是，他在1979年搬到了纽约市。他当时正试图成为一名全职演员。所以我想知道他是不是只是想在1979年咬一口大苹果（纽约）。
A bite?
I'm not confident with this.
A bite.
That's the least.
It's the worst.
We were hip, but I'm going to allow it.
A bite.
咬一口？咬一口？我对这个没有信心。咬一口。这是最轻的。这是最糟的。我们很时髦，但我准许了。咬一口。
Oh, my head of the apple.
Smart.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Arbjarf.
Smartless.
哦，我的大苹果。聪明。Smartless由贝内特·巴尔比科、迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞和罗布·阿尔布贾夫100%有机且手工打造。Smartless。